nice
Bruder von 1, kein Bruder von 0 funktioniert und alles
muss bloß gucken ob alles funktioniert
Clorx HD sieben Monate, Dankeschön. Max du bist doch unabhängig von Toilettenpapier mit meinem Super Klo. Naja so einfach ist das ganze auch wiederum nicht.
Ich meine ich zeig das ich zeig das Klo hier nochmal. Ich mein mann wer hat der hat ne. So ganz unabhängig davon.
8000 plus, so ganz unabhängig von Klopapier bin ich auch nicht.
Gibt es hier irgendwo ein schönes Bild von dem Klo? Alter das Scamtrain ist schon wieder am Start geht der instant hier Schlag auf Schlag hier.
Kiyokun am Start Stufe 1 neun Monate am Start. Huge Sub. Da kommt der Patrick hinterher mit neun Monaten auch am Start. Und der Hype Train ist schon fast voll.
Das Scamtrain läuft Leute. Ähm ich überleg grad noch was. Noch mehr hier hat der Hainoop sechs Monate.
Ne noch kein Sonntag. So zu der Frage hin ob ich abhängig, ob ich nicht, hier sieht man es schön, unabhängig von Klopapier bin so einfach ist es nicht.
Wie gesagt das Klo hat da hier nen Föhn und hier so ne Wasserdüse. Man sieht das leider nicht, weil die sich der Meinung sind ah hier doch. Kriegt man schön das Wasser an Poppes.
Eigentlich können wir so sagen ich hab ja ein Video dazu gemacht. Kack FPS. Da hatte ich doch das alte iPhone an. So und hier sieht man das jetzt hier kommt gleich das Ding rausgefahren und sprayed einem den Hintern ab.
Das ist schon 2013 das ist ewig lang her. So und neben kommt dann ein Föhn rausgefahren. Guck hier da ist der Föhn. Also ganz unabhängig von Klopapier bin ich auch nicht.
Denn 75 Cent. Dankeschön. Ach Bits zählen da auch dazu. Ich hab ja übrigens nichts spezifisches vor. So zumindest ich bin nicht ganz unabhängig von Klopapier.
Denn guck mal ich hab sogar nen Vorsprung von meinem Video. Hahaha lustig. Denn man braucht trotzdem noch ein bisschen Klopapier.
Erstens braucht man ein bisschen Klopapier ab und zu mal um schlicht und ergreifend um hier ein bisschen sauber zu machen drum herum.
Und wenn man ich benutze den Föhn nicht. Ich benutze ich benutze den Föhn nicht. Das heißt ich lass mir den Bombers absprayen vom Wasserstrahl.
Und danach steh ich auf und putz ab mit Klopapier. Das Social Distancing Dashboard. Das können wir uns jetzt mal angucken.
Die Besitzenden abputzen alle. Genau so wie die Noobs auf Twitter am Start gewesen sind wieder.
So ich muss mal kurz den Chat schauen. Es gab ja hier eben ein paar Questions. Moin Desinator.
Irgendjemand hat was mit VPN gefragt gerade. Ich seh es nicht. Ah hier der Umut hat gefragt.
Ich muss für ein paar Leute VPNs in das Büro einrichten. Was empfiehlst du da? Kommt drauf an mit was für einer Hardware.
Auf was soll das ganze laufen? Habt ihr da schon Hardware für? Wollt ihr da eigene Hardware für installieren?
Was habt ihr für Clients? Das ist nicht so pauschal einfach zu beantworten.
Ihr habt Happypoo. Was ist Happypoo? Kann man da nach suchen? Ist das safe? Happypoo? DM ja das scheint safe zu sein.
What? Was ist Happypoo? Das ist ja cool. Das füllst du mit warmem Wasser auf und dann sprayst du dir den Bobs ab.
Das ist ja nice was es nicht alles gibt. Das wollen wir jetzt mal auf YouTube angucken. Happypoo. Intim mit Nico.
Da passt irgendwie die Musik gerade wunderbar zu dem Video.
Was ist das für ein Schlüssel?
Das tut ja weh. Das tut ja weh.
Po Ries.
Was mich bei Happypoo übelst verwirrt ist. Happypoo hat den Bobs oben auf dem Kopf. Aber die Beine hat er unten.
Hat er oben den großen Po und hier unten noch mal einen. Weil ansonsten würde er ja quasi aus dem Kopf scheißen.
Was? Ich weiß nicht ob die sich da... Was ist daran sexy?
Wenn der dich mit so einem Wasserstrahl von hinten anschießt der bis zum Mars geht. Ich glaube da willst du nicht im Weg sitzen.
Comfy Klo.
Es ist cool zu sehen was es alles gibt. Also das heißt hätte ich nicht hier mein Klo mit eingebauten dann würde ich mir wahrscheinlich auch Happypoo kaufen.
Happypoo klingt echt gut. Hat derjenige geantwortet mit VPN?
Was ist das für ein Schlüssel?
Ja dann probier mal WireGuard. WireGuard ist einfach aufzusetzen und die Kleinen sind auch ganz gut. Ich hätte gesagt wenn du das jetzt mit einem vorhandenen Cisco Switch oder irgendwie Gedöns machen willst was weiß gar nicht ob die Switches das überhaupt können.
Dann wärs wahrscheinlich IPsec geworden. Aber nachdem du freie Wahl hast drum herum dann würde ich es mit WireGuard probieren. WireGuard ist einfach zu installieren.
Happypoo war sogar in der Höhle der Löwen. Okay das gucke ich nicht.
Ich wollte euch mal was cooles zeigen. Guck mal was ich gefunden habe hier für Linux Kommandozeile. Ein Corona Tracker für die Kommandozeile.
Das ist doch nice oder? Wow okay das unterstützt wohl irgendwie keine Farben.
Guck der Nigga hat einen. Und wir haben 21.854. Was sagt denn da Worldinfo Corona dazu?
Alter Leute das ist ein Land. Ich kann auch nichts dafür dass das Land so heißt. Guck mal das ist ziemlich aktuell. Mich würde ja mal interessieren wo das die Daten herzieht.
Man kann das bestimmt auch sortieren nach Land oder so. Ah hier guck US. Das ist hier für Coconaland. Die Jungfrauensel.
So gibt es auch DE. Ah Germany hat nur eins zusammen. Moment warum ist Confirmed für die einzelnen Länder niedriger als in der Gesamtübersicht?
Achso ich brauche die Live Übersicht. Gucken wir mal das hier. Germany machen. Dann sind wir aktuell. Guck mal man sieht sogar den Rank.
Wie kriegt man das jetzt gescheit geprintet? So hier huge. Geben wir mal Het. Nee minus N ist es. Minus N 5. Oder nicht?
Ich bin zu dumm die einfachsten Linux Commando Zeilen Tools zu verwenden. Wahnsinn oder? Aber wir können ja nachgucken.
Wieso? Ich habe es doch richtig gemacht. Ich habe es doch richtig gemacht. Minus N 5. Warum geht das nicht? Warum geht das nicht? Von hinten geht es.
Aber von vorne geht es nicht. Warum ist das so? Na gut es ist ganz einfach. Wir müssen einfach noch ein bisschen steigen in den Corona Zahlen. Dann geht es bei uns auch.
Ah jetzt mit 20 funktioniert es. Ok was auch immer. Also bei uns sind 9 Leute gestorben. Kann Watch eigentlich Colors?
Watch kann Colors? Oh jetzt wird es aber advanced hier. Guck mal jetzt machen wir nämlich einfach so. Und dann aktualisiert sich das immer. Ist das nicht nice?
Oh hier. Bam. So dann muss mal Col noch minus N, dass das Quiet S machen. Nee minus Q, minus S. Was ist Quiet bei Col?
WTF? Warum kann ich mir Basic Linux Commando Zeilen Zeug nicht merken? Was war Quiet? Silent was? Minus S? Minus S.
Warum ist dieser Scheiß in jedem Commando Zeilen Programm anders? Minus kleines. Warum müssen die überall, mal ist es minus N, mal ist es minus Q, mal ist es minus S?
Die werden sich nicht ein. Ich guckte mal. So. Jetzt aktualisiert sich das alle 2 Sekunden und da habe ich meinen Corona Tracker im Terminal.
Das ist doch Pock oder? Max ich hätte auch eine Frage zum Thema Side to Side VPN. Mit Zertifikatsbasierter Authentifizierung.
Da habe ich meine Abschlussarbeit drüber gemacht. Das heißt aber nicht, dass ich mich da heute mit noch auskenne.
So was hat denn hier der? Ist das der? Nee das ist ein anderer oder? Das ist nicht der mit dem Bahn-Mining-Talk. Oder ist das der mit dem Bahn-Mining-Talk?
Oder ist der Name? Oder ist der Name einfach nur ähnlich? Nee Grisel heißt der. Und das ist ein Kreisel.
Das ist ein anderer. Moin After Maths F4 Quick Maths. Dort steht eine Linungskiste die du managest Umut. Ja dann WireGuard. Dann würde ich WireGuard nehmen.
Was ist heute der Plan? Ich hab keinen Plan. Also das ist wie immer.
Ich hab gedacht ich mach einfach mal den Stream an. Erstens weil ich sonst nichts zu tun hab gerade.
Außerdem weil ich den ganzen Tag rumgebastelt hab am Rechner und keinen Bock habe irgendwie noch weiter zu basteln habe ich mir gedacht ey weißt du was mach einfach mal den Stream an und guck was so geht. Wir werden nachher noch mal gucken ob es noch ein paar Großhändler gibt die noch Klopapier verkaufen.
Weil auf Twitter sind ja mal wieder alle eskaliert. Also nicht alle das stimmt ja nicht. Ich übertreib ja manchmal. Es sind nicht alle eskaliert. Ein paar Leute sind eskaliert. Weil ich das ist übrigens was ist das optimiert für 800x600 und Internet Explorer oder was ist mit Twitter los.
Ich hab ja auf Twitter gepostet dass ich Klopapier bestellt hab. Nämlich 6-9 Schreuen Klopapier. Und da kamen öfters mal so Antworten in die Richtung wie du dummer Spast. Und solche Sachen.
Und ich hätte gar nicht damit gedacht ehrlich gesagt dass dieser Post so viele Leute triggern könnte. Hätte ich nicht vermutet. Man muss sich nämlich mal überlegen was sind denn die Alternativen dazu.
Also gehen wir mal von aus. Oh den Chat zieht man nicht mal im Stream. Der Cute Chat ist weg. Der ist noch vom Playstation Event weg. Jetzt ist der Cute Chat wieder da.
Ups falscher Knopf. Klops Russia 2 Monate auch Dankeschön. Ich hoffe ich hab nichts übersehen.
Gedi Kono 3 Monate abonniert Dankeschön. Huge Sub. Der High Noob ist auch wieder am Start. Weit ich hatte ich schon aber trotzdem. Huge Sub.
Alles übersehen.
Was ich interessant fand dass da einige drüber getriggert waren. Und wenn man sich mal überlegt was sind denn die Alternativen.
Ich bin der Meinung wir wären besser dran würden alle Leute einfach online ihr Klopapier bestellen. Weil dann könnten die Leute die keine Möglichkeit haben oder wirklich mal auf die schnelle was brauchen einfach in den Supermarkt gehen und was holen.
Und alles würde deutlich geplanter und koordinierter laufen wenn du im Vorfeld weißt wer wie viel wohin bestellt hat. Also ich bin der Meinung ich mach das richtig. Und wenn man sich mal überlegt was ist die Alternative.
Auch aktuell würde ich mal sagen schon 3-4 Wochen Vorrat man weiß ja nie vielleicht wird man ja krank. Und wenn man krank ist und das ganze auch schon mal 2-3-4 Wochen dauern kann bis man wieder gesund ist und man am besten da nicht rausgehen sollte in den Supermarkt.
Dann brauchen wir ein bisschen Vorrat. Natürlich sind 96 Rollen ein bisschen viel. Wie kann ich dich mit Prime abonnieren da ich Prime habe es mir aber nicht angezeigt wird. Ganz normal auf dem gleichen Button wie alles andere aber vielleicht hast du ja Twitch und Amazon nicht verknüpft.
Ich hätte ja auch kleinere Menge bestellt anstatt 96 Rollen. Also ich hätte mich auch mit der Hälfte zufrieden gegeben. Aber ich habe bei einem Großhändler bestellt für so einen Bürobedarfladen und der hat halt nur das kleinste war halt 96 Rollen.
So und was ist die Alternative aktuell? Supermärkte geben teilweise nur noch ein Pack pro Person raus. Das heißt wenn man jetzt mal für den Fall der Fälle dass man krank wird einen Vorrat von 3-4 Wochen braucht hast du absolut keine Chance irgendwas zu bekommen.
Und die Alternative ist einfach jetzt sich für eine Woche lang jeden Tag morgens in die Menge zu stellen und jeweils eine Packung Klopapier abzugreifen. Warum soll ich denn mich gerade jetzt in die Menge der Leute stellen im Supermarkt?
Also sprich wenn du jetzt noch kein Corona hast danach hast du es auf jeden Fall. So also ich habe mal ausgerechnet so einen normalen Verbrauch brauchen wir ungefähr mit zwei Personen.
Brauchen wir so ungefähr eins eine Rolle am Tag ungefähr und jetzt wo ich halt auch Homeoffice hab und den ganzen Tag daheim bin im Endeffekt würde ich mal sagen eineinhalb Rollen oder sowas.
Aber ich bin ja auch ein Knäuler und kein Falter. Was ist mit euch los? Was ist mit euch los?
Bring abonniert Twitch bleiben. Dankeschön. Wenn das Greta hört ja da habe ich schon Angst vor. Ja so ist das halt. So ist halt meine wie nennt man es wie soll man es nennen Kackgewohnheiten.
Ich falte nicht ich knäule. Und dann kommt da halt sowas raus und wir sind zwei Personen das heißt wir brauchen ungefähr eine Rolle am Tag.
Natürlich ist da nicht da ist nicht nur Kacken dabei da ist auch Zeug abputzen und sonst was dabei.
Also das heißt das ganze reicht mit 96 Rollen reichen für zwei Personen dann irgendwie so. Ich habe jetzt mal mit eineinhalb Rollen gerechnet mit eineinhalb Rollen so zwei zwei drei Monate vielleicht.
Auskenn Fuchs man braucht da theoretisch auch kein Papier mehr aber ich putze trotzdem noch mal ab danach aber nicht mit zu viel wie sonst.
Sebaru neumordert. Der Cutebot ist am Start. Da ist er. Dankeschön für den Sub. Switch du zwischen Linux und Windows herum.
Ach wie mit Control als mit mit Steuerung Windows links und rechts. Aber wahrscheinlich ist das nicht was du wissen wolltest sondern das ist vor allem der Workstation.
Und hier haben wir unser aktuelles Corona Update. New Cases es geht hoch Leute.
Die Chinesen haben angeblich keine neuen Corona Fälle. Da habe ich so meine Zweifel an der Informations Politik aus China.
Blute da nicht dahinter wenn man mit so viel Klopapier rumschrubbt. Übung macht den Meister.
Ich muss euch ja auch mal sagen. Ich bin ja selbst ein bisschen schockiert über die Leute. Wie bescheuert die meisten sind. Ich war ich habe es doch. Ich habe es. Ich habe sie auf Twitter gepostet. Ich war. Ich bin zum Rewe gelaufen am Main lang.
Ich bin zum Rewe gelaufen am Main lang und war das erste was ich gesehen habe ist als ich am Main runter gekommen bin. Eine Gruppe von keine Ahnung 15 20 Leuten haben auf einer riesen Deckel gepicknickt am Main.
So schön in der Sonne. Jolo Corona was juckt es mich. Vollkommen egal haben sie sich gedacht. Das ist einfach. Also was man daran wieder sieht ist wenn du dich darauf verlassen musst.
Dass andere Leute das Richtige machen. Dann bist du komplett verlassen. Dann hast du komplett gelitten. Und das Problem an der Sache ist jetzt ja nur.
Dass man normalerweise irgendwie selbst verantwortlich ist aber in dem Fall liegt es ja gar nicht mal an einem selber. So sehr wenn man den Scheiß kriegt.
Und danach war das Problem. Ich bin dann. Ich bin weitergelaufen mich auf dem Rückweg als ich vom Rewe zurückgekommen bin. Also Lidl und Rewe ist da quasi so auf einer Ecke. Und als ich zurückgekommen bin kam mir ein Familienausflug entgegen.
Drei Familien also drei Paare mit Kinderwagen die haben quasi die Brücke über den Main haben gerade den Kinderwagen die in die Treppe hochgetragen. Und das waren 15 Leute oder so.
Auch irgendwie keine Ahnung. Drei Familien jeder irgendwie gefühlt. Keine Ahnung. Drei vier Kinder. Ach keine Ahnung. Es war viel. Es war voll. Und da habe ich mir auch gedacht wie bescheuert. Wie bescheuert kann man eigentlich sein. Die Leute gehen danach zu Opa und Oma wahrscheinlich zum Abendessen.
Und denken sich nichts bei. Und danach beschweren sie sich noch warum sie keiner davor beschützt hätte weil Oma und Opa an Corona verreckt ist.
Das sind Leute die kommen nie im Leben auf die Idee dass sie selber daran schuld sind. Kennt ihr so Leute die permanent am rumheulen sind.
Dass die Welt gemeint zu ihnen ist. So nach dem Motto hier wäre ich nicht richtig behandelt und hier haben sie mich wieder schon verarscht. Und ich habe ja auch nur eine Fünf gekriegt weil mich der Lehrer nicht mag.
Und hier bin ich eigentlich auch immer nur verarscht worden. Dass dann irgendwie mal einer von den Leuten auf die Idee kommen würde dass das mit an ihnen liegt.
Ich meine man kann immer Pech haben. Klar. Du kannst auch komplett unverschuldet über einen Haufen gefahren werden. Das liegt nicht immer nur an dir.
Aber wenn du permanent immer nur Scheiße baust und der Meinung ist die Welt hat sich gegen dich verschworen und dir nie was Gutes passiert dann sollte man sich vielleicht mal überlegen ob man nicht da selbst mit dran schuld ist.
Und das sind genau die gleichen Leute. Machen Familienausflug mit drei Paaren. Gehen danach zu Opa und Oma. Stecken Opa und Oma mit Corona an.
Opa und Oma stirbt da dran und danach wird rumgeheult. Warum hat der Staat nichts gemacht? Warum hat die Polizei nichts gemacht? Warum hat das Land nichts gemacht?
Warum hat das Krankenhaus nichts gemacht? Warum ist unser Sozialsystem? Warum ist unsere Krankenversicherung so schlecht? Warum ist alles so schlecht? Und wir haben doch nichts gemacht.
Immer der gleiche Scheiß. Die Leute sind so unglaublich bescheuert. Das gibt es nicht.
Und es geht ja gar nicht so sehr darum dass man die ganze Sache komplett verhindern könnte.
Das ist das was ich mir vor Anfang an frage mit was sagen kann. Es geht ja gar nicht darum dass das komplett verhindert wird dass man sich ansteckt.
Das heißt es gibt durchaus Kombinationen. Es hat gerade einer im Chat geschrieben die Mutter arbeitet beim Rewe und so.
Klar die Chancen dass du es kriegst früher oder später sind relativ hoch und bei dir wahrscheinlich eher früher.
Aber insgesamt bringt das einiges. Ich habe eben gerade eine Grafik gesehen zu Südkorea. Ich muss gerade mal gucken ob ich die finde.
Eine Grafik zu Südkorea, Japan und den restlichen Ländern. Wo man halt sieht wo die Bevölkerung diszipliniert ist und wo nicht.
Hier warte mal ich habe es gefunden Leute. Guckt euch das mal an. Japan, Südkorea, gerade die Japaner sind ja ultra diszipliniert was solche Sachen angeht.
Wenn in Japan einer sagt machst du den nicht, dann machst du das auch nicht. Das ist nicht so wie bei uns wenn da die Polizei sagt machst du den nicht.
Dann sagt bei uns die Leute erst mal alter null Polizei fick dich alte Polizei. Dann macht das halt keiner.
In Japan ist das anders. In Japan wenn da einer sagt machst du den nicht, dann machst du den nicht.
Und in Japan ist es wahrscheinlich schon überhaupt beleidigend wenn du es überhaupt sagen musst dass du nicht selbst allein auf die Idee gekommen bist.
Also Japan überhaupt kein Ding. Südkorea hatte am Anfang, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern wir hatten letztens hier einen aus Südkorea im Stream.
Da waren wir hier so irgendwie. Da waren wir ungefähr auf der Höhe. Südkorea und Deutschland. Und da hat man es halt gesehen in Südkorea funktioniert der Scheiß.
Du musst nicht ins Internetcafe. Du musst nicht in irgendwelche anderen Dinger was halt die Südkoreaner so gerne machen oder in Karaoke graben was weiß ich.
Die kriegen das ja auch gemacht. Was ist übrigens auch eine Sache die mir nicht ganz einleuchtet ist.
Ich mein ja. Der normale Mundschutz der bringt erst mal nichts.
Okay dann ist natürlich die nächste Frage die ich mir stelle. Es gibt ja Mundschutz der was bringt.
Zumindest mehr als dieser normale Mundschutz. Und wo der normale Mundschutz auch schon was bringt. Ich kann den Link auch in den Chat posten.
Wo der normale Mundschutz was bringt ist auch das man die anderen Leute nicht ansteckt.
So und wisst ihr was ich mich frage. Warum gibt es nicht am Eingang von jedem Supermarkt. Ich meine der Supermarkt ist das Ding wo aktuell alle noch hingehen und rein müssen.
Warum gibt es dann nicht einfach entweder die Regel nur mit Maske rein. Und das würde allerdings nur funktionieren wenn es auch Masken gäbe für die Leute.
Weil dann hast du zumindest die Gefahr ein bisschen geringer dass du andere Leute ansteckst wenn du so ein Ding auf hast.
Ich hab das Gefühl wir machen das ein bisschen.
Ey bei uns im Supermarkt bei uns im EDK steht so ein Security Dude rum.
Ja ja ihr könnt keine bestellen das ist klar. Ich sag ja auch nicht dass der Einzelhandel oder generell die Supermärkte sich darum kümmern müssten.
Das ist so eine Sache wo ich tatsächlich in dem Fall mal das jeweilige Land oder generell auch unsere Regierung in Deutschland in der Pflicht sehen würde.
Dass man sowas eben hat. Ich mein wir haben ja für alles irgendwelche Vorräte aber daran anscheinend nicht.
Der Shop wo ich mein Klopapier bestellt hab. Also da wo sie mich hier geflammt haben. Der hat ja auch geschrieben dass es sein kann dass die Bestellung ein bisschen später kommt.
Weil sie zuerst Krankenhäuser beliefern. Wer bin ich der Letzte der was dagegen sagt.
Ja gut ich hab eh kein Problem ich hab ja hier meine ich hab ja hier meine Maske. Also wenn ich wirklich mal in irgendwie ein total verseuchtes Gebiet muss dann zieh ich mir einfach dieses Ding hier auf.
Wo hab ichs? Hier wenn ich mein wirklich total verseuchtes Ding muss dann zieh ich mir das Ding hier auf und dann ist vorbei. Da hat der Virus keine Chance.
Da mach ich mal Metro Cosplay.
Bei uns im Lidl auch nur ja ich hab's gesehen. Bei uns im Edeka ist es auch so da haben sie durch einen halben Laden solche Abstandstreifen jetzt hingemacht.
Masken haben fast alle Ausatmventile die ungefiltert sind. Ich weiß nicht ob so ein normaler Mundschutz der so ein normaler OP Mundschutz der hat bestimmt keine Ausatmventile.
Deswegen hilft es ja auch was dagegen dass man andere Leute ansteckt. Bei der Geschichte könnte es tatsächlich sein dass der Ausatmventile hat nicht andere Leute anstecke.
Allerdings das Ding zieh ich mir ja auch nur an wenn ich mich selber nicht anstecken will.
Was sind das für Filter? Das sind P3R das ist gegen Virus gegen Viren und so. Da gibt es so ne Tabelle gegen was das hilft haben wir letztens im Stream angeguckt.
Wen juckt das Ausatmen? Das Ausatmen ist ganz entscheidend weil zumindest bei dem Fall wenn man in den Supermarkt geht und nicht viele andere Leute anstecken will.
Weil das Problem ist ja du weißt ja oftmals gar nicht ob du es hast. Du bist ja schon lange ansteckend bevor du es merkst.
Naja gut aber jetzt genug zu dem Zeug. Aber man sieht hier mit ein bisschen Disziplin funktioniert das ganze ganz gut.
So ja das hier das Ding zieh ich an dass ich mich nicht anstecke ganz klar. Ich hatte es bis jetzt noch nicht an. Ich hab es mir ja auch wie gesagt nur gekauft.
Nicht für Corona oder so ich hab es mir ja davor schon gekauft für Schimmel und Zeug wo man Kram sauber machen muss.
Aber jetzt ist es halt ganz praktisch dass ich das Teil habe. Wenn ich wirklich mal irgendwo hin muss wo die totale Seuche ist dann zieh ich das Ding an.
Aber was man finde ich hier ganz gut sieht ist mit ein bisschen Disziplin funktioniert das.
Die Amis haben komplett gelitten. Die haben ja aktuell eher so die Sorgen wo kriege ich noch schnell Waffen her.
Ich hab zu wenig Waffen ich brauch mehr Waffen also scheiß auf Corona hauptsache noch mal eine MP5 gekauft.
Mark spiegelt sich im XR5 Film.
Erstmal noch eine MP5 gekauft wobei ich weiß gar nicht ob eine MP5 da jetzt im Trend ist. Was kaufen sich denn die Amis aktuell so?
Weiß nicht. M4 vielleicht ein M4 oder so.
AR15 keine Ahnung ich weiß nicht was die sich so kaufen aber zumindest AR15 glaube ich auch.
AR15 ist doch eine M4 oder?
Ein RPG. Man kann ja schon mal für den Ernstfall aufrüsten.
So und die haben gerade richtig gelitten weil die haben ja aktuell auch Ferien.
Also ne die in den USA haben die haben ja irgendwie gerade was ist denn das?
Osterferien oder sowas in der Richtung.
Und da geht es jetzt halt richtig hoch. Da geht es halt voll ab gerade.
Ich betone nochmal dummer Spaß.
Ich muss immer lachen wenn ich die Comments lese teilweise.
Die Leute waren so ultra getriggert.
Dummer Spaß hatten wir hier. Dann hatten wir noch hier Leute die sich drüber aufgeregt haben.
So dumm das reicht doch. Warum so viel leicht unsolli...
Oh den kenne ich übrigens. Den kenne ich übrigens RL hier.
Das fällt mir gerade ein.
Ja also teilweise voll aufgeregt.
Aber dann war das halt das kleinste was es gibt.
Ok was zum geilweiß... das hat ihr vorhin irgendjemand geschickt.
Was ist das Social Distancing Dashboard?
Ich muss mal kurz schauen. Hab ich irgendwelche Subscriber übersehen vielleicht?
Das wäre ja nicht auszudenken.
Ne sieht nicht so aus.
Zuletzt hatten wir den Sebaro.
Was für eine grafische Oberfläche nutzt du unter deinem Linux i3-WM?
Also Leute wenn ihr irgendwelche Fragen habt sei es zur Technik, zu Linux, Computergrams, Technik allgemein, Heimautomatik oder sonst was.
Hauts einfach raus ich hab heute nichts spezielles vor im Stream.
Was hältst du vom...
Saggesetz wie die letzten Tage das Thema bei den meisten Finanzie... was?
Flozax 96 ne ne ich hab bestellt.
Ich hab das Ding erstmal nur Klopapier Stream genannt und ich wollte mal gucken ob es nicht vielleicht...
Ich hatte nämlich vorhin die übelste Big Brain Idee.
Ich hab mir gedacht gibt es nicht vielleicht Österreich aus Klopapier?
Also nicht Österreich aus Klopapier gibt es nicht vielleicht Klopapier aus Österreich bestellt?
Kann man das machen vielleicht haben die ja mehr.
Was brauchst du um eine Lampen alles zu steuern?
Wenn du deine Lampen steuern willst dann ist die beste Variante...
Also wir reden jetzt mal hier von ein und ausschalten.
Dann ist die beste Sache die du dir kaufen kannst ein Shelly.
Hat mit Cloud nichts zu tun die Dinger funktionieren komplett offline wenn man das will.
Und zwar den da ein Shelly 1 kaufst du dir.
Das ist ein Relay das kannst du unter den Lichtschalter machen.
Das heißt du kannst dein Licht nach wie vor mit dem Schalter ein und ausschalten allerdings auch per Wlan.
Das ist das beste.
Was hältst du von VBA? Nix.
Also von Visual Basic bin ich als ich kein großer Fan.
Ich glaube VBA ist halt das einzige wo man Office Krams automatisieren kann.
Wie groß war noch mal der Nass und wie viel Speicher ist aktuell noch frei?
Also ich hab ja vorher hatte ich ja meine 4 HE Kiste.
Also sprich das Ding hatte ich ja vorher hier oben die Kiste.
Da waren dreimal 10TB drin.
Und jetzt habe ich nur noch eine Kiste weil das komplett oversized war.
Und jetzt habe ich nur noch eine Kiste da ist eine 12TB Platte drin.
Und eine 12TB Platte Backup wo nächtlich einmal gesyncht wird.
Und das meiste ich glaube 2TB sind insgesamt belegt mit allem was drauf ist.
Also das hält sich echt in Grenzen.
Was schlägt er noch auf? Keine Ahnung.
Ja Sebaro oder? Da fließt die Kohle.
Leider habe ich so das Gefühl oder ich könnte mir vorstellen Sebaro hat gerade geschrieben.
Was ich ganz interessant finde sonst ist nie Geld im Staat oder der EU da.
Aber wenn es im Notfall gibt kann man eben 750 Milliarden locker machen.
Mich würde es ja sehr interessieren ob von diesen 750 Milliarden auch woanders was ankommt als bei riesengroß Unternehmen.
Also sprich kommt von den 750 Milliarden auch was an bei kleineren, bei mittelständischen und vielleicht auch bei den ein oder anderen Leuten die es wirklich nötig haben.
Neun bekommst du Harz. Ne. Ich gehe ganz normal arbeiten.
Ich bin ein bisschen hinten dran mit dem Chat.
Kannst du eventuell was von deinem OSM Projekt zeigen? Soll ich? Soll ich? Wollt ihr das sehen?
Also ich kann es ja noch mal sagen ich bin ja gerade dabei mit einem, da muss ich aber die Url ausblenden.
Ich bin da gerade dabei mit meinem, mit einem, mit einem Kollegen.
Also mit dem verstehe ich mich gut, deswegen passt das.
Das kann man nur, kann man so, so Projekte kann man nur machen mit Leuten wo man sich gut versteht.
Wir sind da gerade dabei ein ja Tool zu programmieren für wie heißt das so für Betriebe die, die quasi Installateure haben.
Also sprich für einen Klempner oder für einen Heizungsbaumensch oder so.
Wo die ihre Termine planen können sprich da kannst du eintragen welche Kunden haben Wartungsverträge.
Und da kannst du sagen ok jetzt stehen mal wieder bei den Kunden mit Wartungsverträgen steht jetzt mal demnächst wieder ein Besuch an Heizungswartung.
Und das errechnet dir dann optimale oder nahezu optimale Routen, optimale Routen an sich gibt es ja nicht.
Nahezu optimale Routen wie man die Leute abfahren kann.
Ich kann euch was von zeigen wenn ihr wollt ja.
Aktuell basiert das ganze, ich kann, ich kann was, ich muss aber die Url ausblenden.
Ja Umut kann ich was und sagt mir jetzt nichts.
Hey Max hast du mal was mit On-Fifth-Cams gemacht möchte ich gerne den On-Fifth-Stream einer China-Camp aufzeichnen.
Ja und zwar was ich dazu sagen kann On-Fifth ist kein Streaming-Protokoll.
Ich weiß gar nicht ob man das überhaupt On-Fifth ausspricht.
Das ist ein Standard über XML wo man Daten zu der Kamera abfragen kann.
Die Streams gehen nicht über On-Fifth die Streams gehen ganz normal über RTSP oder andere Geschichten.
Also für die Streams brauchst du kein On-Fifth du brauchst nur die Stream-Adresse die musst du rauskriegen.
Das andere ist nur ein reines Info-Ding.
Welche Shell benutzt du? Das ist ZSH in dem Gnome Terminal und aber kein riesen Plugin-Gedöns.
Ich muss gerade den Chat ein bisschen aufholen Leute ich bin nicht schnell genug.
Ja Daddy Khan wir wünschen dir alle viel Glück ich weiß zwar nicht was ein PIC Simulator ist.
Aber du machst das schon.
Wie hast du deine Heizung automatisiert?
Sagt mal Leute hatte ich nicht ein Tool programmiert was die ganzen Stream-Fragen aufzeichnet?
Ich hatte doch da mal was gebastelt hier.
Ich hatte doch mal ein Tool programmiert was die ganzen Stream-Fragen aufzeichnet dass ich nichts übersehe.
Twitch-Chat.
Ist es doch.
Warum hab ich denn das nicht mehr an?
Warum hab ich denn das nicht mehr laufen?
Sollen wir das mal ausprobieren?
Das könnte ich jetzt nämlich gerade gebrauchen jaja.
Nehradorn Stufe 1 acht Monate lang schön.
Wow Java.
One Case.
Was ist das?
Mein Java brauche ich um eine.NET IDE aufzumachen da ist schon irgendwas verkehrter.
Ah jetzt gehts.
Wo habe ich denn hier mein.
Mein Twitch-Chat.
Twitch-Chat.
Okay.
Ist das das?
Twitch-Chat. Private Message.
Das ist das.
Okay starten wir mal.
Okay ich beantworte nochmal schnell alle anderen Fragen dann.
Warum geht denn das nicht?
Kann man mit einem neuen.NET Framework nicht ein altes.NET Programm starten?
Was ist denn das für ein Schwachsinn?
Da muss ich gleich mal gucken.
Dein Friseur hat Insolvenz angemeldet feels Batman.
Neonymus Stufe 1 Dankeschön.
Sixhead Sub.
Sag mal ich suche nach einer Möglichkeit über USM lieflet 3D Objekte.
Ne da kenne ich nichts zu.
Okay so.
Warum kann man das nicht starten?
Kann man das Projekt vielleicht einfach upgraden?
Das Problem hatte ich noch nie.
Target Framework.
Ah man muss.NET Standard Targeten dann geht das wahrscheinlich.
Und jetzt.
Was geht ab?
Warum geht mein Zeug nicht mehr?
What?
Warum geht mein Shit nicht mehr?
Oh was ist das? Warum ist das kaputt?
Warum geht mein Frage Lock Tool nicht mehr?
Moment.
Ich mein.
Das ist nicht das Frage Lock Tool Leute.
Das ist gar nicht das Frage Lock Tool.
Das Frage Lock Tool war viel länger.
Da war eine ganze ASP.NET Anwendung drum herum.
Warte mal das ist gar nicht das richtige.
Das ist gar nicht das richtige.
Wo ist denn mein?
Wo ist denn mein Twitch Chat Tool?
Die Console App 1 wird es ja wohl nicht sein.
Ne das haben wir nicht unter Windows gemacht oder?
Ist das die neue VM? Wo ist das denn?
Unter Windows ist es glaube ich net.
Das war ein Richard Studio?
Ne.
Ne ne ne ne ne ne.
Wenn ich ja meine Programme mal ordentlich nennen würde.
Web Application 2.
Ok von wann ist denn das hier?
Juni.
Ok wir fangen jetzt mal von hinten an.
Web Application 2.
Huge Benennung.
True.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Das ist die Blazer.
Die Blazer To Do App.
Ok.
Die ist es schonmal nicht.
Das hab ich unter Linux gemacht Leute.
Das ist nicht unter Windows.
DHL, DPD, Versandtracker, Windows Forms.
Nein.
Scanner, Windows Forms ist es auch nicht.
Haben wir auch schon Detektor.
Wo ist denn das?
Wow.
Wir haben noch ne Web Application 2.
Haben wir noch? Die hatten wir gerade glaube ich.
Warum machst du jetzt 2007 auf?
Sag mal.
Unordentliches Fuck.
Das ist die komische Blazer App.
Die wollen wir nicht.
Web Application 1.
Leute das war unter.
Das war ne eigene VM.
Nein.
Das war einer meiner ganz normalen Linux VM.
Wo wir das gemacht haben.
Also unter Windows ist es nicht.
Hätte ich den Kram mal damals geproggers?
Ne das ist das Hardware Ratool.
Ist das unter Windows?
Was?
Echt?
Ne.
Na gut.
Wenn das unter Windows gewesen wäre.
Dann müsste das hier dabei sein.
So.
Guck mal.
Da sind sogar Sachen von 2018 dabei.
2019 haben wir nur.
Haben wir nur ein paar Sachen.
Wo hab ich die?
Das ärgert mich jetzt.
Wo hab ich hier mein Tool hin?
Hab ich das vielleicht gelöscht?
Hab ich das mal irgendwann gelöscht?
Aus Versehen?
Ok.
Wo könnte das noch sein?
Vielleicht hier in Stream?
Ok.
Feind.
Ich will jetzt aber hier keinen Feind machen.
Weil ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin.
Was da alles vielleicht noch drauf hat.
Wo ich jetzt will, dass man das sieht.
Aber auch mit dem Feind kann ich machen.
Sieht man den halt nicht.
Feind.
Komm wir suchen jetzt mal nach hier.
Nach einem.
Wir suchen mal alles hier.
Also Corona ist es schon mal nicht.
Ah.
Download.
Moment.
Suchst du das Tool, das du auf Fiverr neu programmieren lassen wolltest?
Korrekt.
Weil ich gucken wollte, was die Inder da draus so machen.
So das hier war es nicht.
Da haben wir gerade reingeguckt.
Das war das Falsche.
Genau.
So.
Was haben wir da oben noch zu bieten?
Das ist es nicht.
Moment.
Im Trash?
Actions?
Nee, das war es anderes.
Das war es anderes.
Downloads Twitch.
Das ist aber glaube ich das, was der Inder programmiert hat.
Watcher?
Ist das für die Webcams?
Was auch immer Remapper sein soll.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was für was das ist.
Dann habe ich ein net 3.
Da kann ich mein Grama gescheit benennen.
Nee, das ist nicht die neu aufgesetzte VM.
Pepega Board hieß das.
Genau.
Pepega Board.
Pepega.
Ist weg? Ich weiß nicht, wo das Pepega-Bottel ist.
Nein, das habe ich nicht gesagt. Pepega.
Pepega.
Warum ist das- Das kann er jetzt sagen. Ich lösche nie was. Warum soll ich ausgerechnet das gesucht haben?
Na gut, mehr- Aber warum soll eine Fuzzy Search mehr finden? Das ist ja im Prinzip schon.
contains
Spack Spack das stream. Oh leute
Oje
MonkaS
Warte mal leute
Ah jetzt gehts wieder
Okay
Unity Media, äh Vodafone, Vodafone in 20. Ich hab den Scheiß echt gelöscht. Ich glaub's net
Ich lösche nie so ich lösche nie Programme
Ne den Telekom Anschluss hab ich nicht mehr als Fallback
Ich lösche nie Programme, aber das PP-Garboard ist weg
Na das programmier ich heute bestimmt net noch mal
Sebaro haben wir noch den stream im archiv irgendwo das hab ich unter linux gemacht leute ich bin mir da ziemlich sicher
Das habe ich unter linux gemacht ziemlich sicher
Okay
Trepp
Anscheinend hab ich's weggeschmissen
Das hab ich auf jeden fall vor ein paar monaten geht der so schlau bin ich auch schon
Streamer fragentool 30.06. Woher wisst ihr das woher wisst ihr das denn
Habe ich das auf github gepusht ne oder wahrscheinlich nicht so wie ich mich kenne
Habe ich das habe ich das auf github wahrscheinlich nicht
Ne
Fuck
Wann hab ich gemacht 30.06
Was nein
Fuck
Hier
Ja
Ich habe es doch unter linux gemacht sag ich doch net drei
Drei das hat man doch gerade gefunden ja ah benahmung big brain benahmung leute net drei
Mh, huge name yes excellent excellent excellent da ist es
Es ist
Huge geht das überhaupt ich muss mal kurz alle fragen löschen
So ihr müsst jetzt mal etwa bloß irgendwas schreiben
Oh es funktioniert leute ich
Find's geil wenn wenn zeug was man gebaut hat funktioniert ja
Ja das gesamte archiv auf meinem nass
Ja sehr schön also hätte ich den kram ordentlich benannt
Aber wir sind sind wir gut drauf gekommen oder net drei
Woops
Warum ich den kram so ultra ppega benannt
Das tool hat betta twitch tv support wenn man
sich den browser plugin installiert
Ich hatte mir meine es gibt einen browser add-on das das macht quasi alles
jegliches html macht sie eben aus
Wie schaut es jetzt bei meiner heizung aus die funktioniert seitdem der technikos da war
Die richtigen sechs header für die programme ja naja
Jetzt bin ich ja froh okay
Wo kriege ich globapier her dass das fragen sich nicht fragt sich nur du dich gerade
Heizung sieht gut aus
Ach so ich wollte euch ja also ich habe es ja vorhin nicht mitgekriegt ich habe jetzt erzählt was für ein program wir gerade am basteln sind
dieses routen optimierungs zeug für installateure
Jetzt jetzt weil es jemand vorhin gefragt hat interessiert das noch mehr was ich da am basteln will mit meinem kollege zusammen
Dann kann ich es euch nämlich mal zeigen da muss ich aber irgendwie die url unkenntlich machen
Da sag ich gleich was zu ok wie mache ich das jetzt ohne dass ich euch die url zeige
Da sag ich gleich was zu so okay wie mache ich das jetzt ohne dass ich euch die url zeige
Okay das war probieren moment mir tutti unter
Browser vollscreen
Das ist mir zu
ja das ist mir zu gefährlich wir machen das jetzt anders capture window capture chrome
ich meine dann sieht man jetzt ein bisschen was nicht
aber wir werden es überleben wobei wisst ihr was wir machen es einfach so
da ist es zwar ein bisschen gestreckt aber was soll es
exzellent also dann zeige ich euch mal
machten und rüber war es Verkehr
Oh, Taskbar!
MonkaS!
Haha!
So.
Huge.
Ja, es ist nicht so wild, wenn ich das liege, dann schalte ich das einfach aus.
Ihr wisst ja, was ich jetzt mache, ich mache jetzt einfach so, gebe die Url ein.
Ah, yes!
Excellent!
So.
Ja, jetzt kann ich wieder einplatten.
Ha!
Also.
Es sieht ein bisschen komisch langgezogen aus, weil der Browser jetzt nicht ganz seitens
gedenkt ist.
Also.
Sind übrigens keine echten Kundendaten, nur mal so zur Info, ne?
Also wer jetzt fragt, denkt das sind echte, das ist alles, alles fake?
Das ist alles fake, also sprich, das ist kein Leak, das wird beim Starten vom Programm
automatisch random generiert.
Und zwar mit, nicht Faker, das ist aber so ein Faker-Klon, und zwar mit Bogus, genau.
Mit Bogus, das generiert Fake-Fake-Daten.
Achso, ihr sehts jetzt gar nicht, ne?
Ihr könnts ja gar nicht sehen, WTF.
Ich hab's euch gerade im anderen Browser gezeigt, aber ihr seht ja gar nix.
So, zumindest, also was man jetzt alles machen kann, ist folgendes, das hier ist ein, also
das ist mit folgender Technik haben wir das Ganze gebaut.
Das ist.NET Core im Backend, das ist Vue.js im Frontend, Vue.tify als GUI-Dingsbums,
die Kram hier, und noch ein paar andere Sachen, aber ich erzähl jetzt nicht alles, nur so
grob.
Wollt ihr das verkaufen?
Wir haben das teilweise sogar schon verkauft, die Idee ist entstanden, weil ein alter, ich
glaub aus der Schule kennt ihr den, also der mit dem ich das mache, der kennt den aus
der Schule, und der hat jetzt nen Heizungsbauer-Laden, und die haben halt sowas gesucht, und haben
gesagt, wist ihr was, sowas könnte man, sowas könnte man auch eigentlich programmieren.
Jetzt haben wir hier so tolle Leute drin, wie Friedrich Grabe, und sowas zum Beispiel.
So, und was man jetzt machen kann, das ist jetzt aktuell einfach nur Prototyp, was man
machen könnte, das heißt noch nicht, dass das am Ende, am Endeffekt so bleibt, also
was man machen kann, ist natürlich einmal hier, man kann natürlich schön suchen, ja,
also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel mal gucken will, wenn man weiß, ah ich hab nen Kunde,
der heißt Grabe, dann kann ich hier nach Grabe suchen, Stelle fest, fuck, ich hab sogar
Achmet Grabe am Start, ja, müsst ihr euren Arbeitgeber darüber informieren, wenn ihr
das braucht und verkauft, äh, gute Frage, nächste Frage, naja, ich hab ja ne Firma,
und das weiß mein Arbeitgeber auch, ja, also ich hab Achmet Grabe, haben auch zur Not
noch hier Danny Grabe, so, man kann auch, man kann natürlich dann auch noch suchen
nach, ähm, keine Ahnung, nach KI E2, ach nee, das geht gar nicht, KI E2, okay, ich hab
das suchen zur Kundennummer funktioniert, aber nicht, ähm, zumindest, was das Coole
an dieser Data Table ist, ja, also wenn wir jetzt mal zum Beispiel gucken wollen, wer
so alles einen Wartungsvertrag hat, kann man das hier filtern nach Wartungsverträgen,
und dann kann man gucken, okay, ähm, bei wem steht denn in nächster Zeit mal wieder
eine Wartung an, dann kann man das nämlich sortieren nach Wartungsverträgen, also ich
hab da ein Dollar hin vorn hingemacht, und nach, ähm, wer mal demnächst wieder dran
ist, und man sieht auch das Ganze ist auch hier ziemlich schnell, also da ist jetzt nix
großartige Ladezeiten oder sonst was, so, dann stellt man fest, ah, okay hier, also
bei, bei, bei Roman Kleis, und bei Femke Hessler, was auch immer das ist, was benutzt
du für ein Backend, das ist.NET, ähm, ASP.NET Core 3.1, oder was das aktuelle ist, so,
also, also, wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, ähm, das hier mal, ich mein, ich wär jetzt lieber
zu Frederik Krabbe gegangen, aber, äh, wir gehen jetzt mal zu, zu, äh, ja, wir wissen
jetzt, dass bei denen demnächst, äh, Wartung ansteht, hier Vito Holzdeppe, zum Beispiel,
wenn wir sagen, ah ja, der Vito, den müssen wir mal besuchen, dann kann man sagen, okay,
mit dem machen wir jetzt einen Termin aus, und mit, mit Leo Geier machen wir einen Termin
aus, und mit, äh, Nikita Maxxen machen wir einen Termin aus, und dem, und dem, und sonst
was, und mit dem machen wir alle Termine aus, so, hier, Brettschneider und Eggenmüller,
die brauchen auch unbedingt was, hehehe, Mehmet Peters brauchen wir auch noch, ja, ich weiß
gar nicht, wo er jetzt ist, ja, hier ist Mehmet, wenn ich übrigens nicht weiß, wo er ist,
kann ich einfach hier sagen, Mehmet, hä, ich fürchte fast, ich hab meine Suche kaputt
gemacht vorhin, ich hab nämlich an der Suche noch rumprogrammiert vorhin, und, ähm, die
gehen irgendwie nicht mehr, Vito, der, der Vito geht aber noch, hä, hab ich mich, hab
ich mich vertippt eben, hab ich mich eben vertippt, weil jetzt geht er, jetzt geht er
wieder, hatte, hatte ich mich, okay, was auch immer, nee, das ist eigentlich alles too lower
und, und, äh, sollte egal sein, gut, wie dem auch sei, also wir haben jetzt, oh, oh, oh,
oh, es laggt, na gut, obei, es laggt gar nicht so großartig, zumindest, jetzt haben wir
das hinzugefügt, haben gesagt, hier mit denen machen wir jetzt alle, machen wir alle, äh,
Termine aus, äh, dann kann man sich noch die, die Informationen zu den unterschiedlichen
Kunden angucken, also zum Beispiel, wenn ich sag, hier, das hier Alessa, nee, wo, wo, wo
ist Frederik Krabbe, ich brauch Frederik Krabbe, wo ist Krabbe, Krabbe, hier, also,
Danny Krabbe, wen haben wir hier, Friedrich, Friedrich Krabbe, also Friedrich Krabbe, der
hat, ähm, der hat seine Adresse geändert, ja, die ist, der wohnt jetzt nicht mal in Kulledinburg,
sondern der wohnt jetzt woanders, ähm, oder hat eine andere Telefonnummer, dann kann man
das hier updaten, man hat noch den Verlauf von vergangenen Terminen, dass man nachgucken
kann, was da ist, ja, übrigens, Friedrich Krabbe hat Lutz75 at Gmail, klingt furchtbar
logisch, ne, da hast du die History, sprich, äh, was für Termine man bei dem hatte und
was man dort für Wartungsarbeiten gemacht hat, das läuft grad auf dem Server, deswegen
hab ich ja auch die URL ausgeplendet, ähm, übrigens, wenn ihr noch coole Ideen habt,
könnt ihr, könnt ihr ja mal was zu, was zu sagen, wie gesagt, das hat bis jetzt noch
den ersten Kontakt nicht, mit der Realität noch nicht überlebt, ja, und am hinten kann
man noch ein paar Notizen reinschreiben, was man, was man haben will, so, bla, bla,
bla, und dann kann man hier oben speichern, äh, das Speichern-Icon hab ich kaputt gemacht,
das Speichern an sich funktioniert eigentlich, das Speichern-Icon hab ich kaputt gemacht,
weil ich hab mir gedacht, hey, es wär doch cool, ähm, wenn das Speichern-Icon nur aktiv
wird, wenn man was geändert hat, jetzt hab ich das Speichern-Icon auf inaktiv gestellt,
allerdings hab ich die Logik verkackt, dass es sich beim Editieren von einem Feld wieder
auf aktiv stellt, naja, ähm, übrigens, wenn ihr, äh, Breenoop kann ich gleich was zu
sagen, schickt das ganz einfach nochmal mit Adwoblos, äh, dass ich das in meinem Tool
gelockt hab, dass ich die Fragen nicht übersehe, also falls ich Fragen vergesse, ne, Adwoblos
davor schreiben, gut ist, so, man kann auch die Kunden taggen, wenn man will, wenn man
zum Beispiel reinschreibt, hier, der Typ ist ultra nervig, kann man zum Beispiel reinschreiben,
so nach dem Motto, keine Ahnung, äh, komplizierte Anlage oder irgendwas, können die Leute reinschreiben,
was sie wollen, jetzt zeig ich euch mal was richtig Cooles, wenn man die Adresse, wenn
man die Adresse eingeben will, ähm, zum Beispiel, ähm, nehmen wir jetzt mal Frankfurt, ja,
sagen wir, sagen wir, sagen wir, der Typ ist jetzt umgezogen nach Frankfurt, also Friedrich
Krabbe, der wohnt jetzt, der wohnt jetzt in Frankfurt, ähm, da kann man jetzt sagen,
Frankfurt, und man sieht ja, krasser Auto complete, ja, und ich kann sogar sagen, HPF
Frankfurt, da kommt am Hauptbahnhof Frankfurt Deutschland raus, ja, oder ich kann auch sagen,
60329 Frankfurt Haupt, äh, ok, so, so advanced ist es dann doch nicht, Hauptbahnhof, ähm,
so, und wenn ich das jetzt anklicke, dann sagt er mir, oh, das geht nicht, könnte der
Kunde nicht, das darf sich derjenige überlegen, das ist mir vollkommen egal, ähm, es wird
mir feststellen, oh, das funktioniert gar nicht, weil, das ist keine richtige Adresse,
so, wenn man, wenn man, ähm, zum Beispiel sagt, ähm, Frankfurt, Zeil, geht auch nicht,
weil das ist keine richtige Adresse, aber wenn man sagt, Frankfurt, Zeil 2, das funktioniert,
also sprich, der hat sogar validation im Hintergrund, dass man sieht, ob das überhaupt stimmt,
was man da eingegeben hat, und das ist mal POG, ja, das ist Massive POG, das ist übrigens
das einzige, was wir haben, was über Google geht, das geht über die Google, ähm, ach
so, wir können mal, Frankfurt, Goethe, Straße, Louis Vuitton Store, zahl die Kollektion
Bar, Fick auf Sponsor auswählen, funktioniert, Q6 in Mannheim, wenn Q6 eine Location ist,
Location Search habe ich da nicht drin, eine Q6, oh doch, ja, funktioniert, Q6, Mannheim,
was ist denn Q6, bitteschön, ne, das funktioniert nicht, weil, das ist keine Adresse im eigentlichen
Grunde, sprich, da fehlt die Straße, der müsste quasi dann noch, wenn man ne Anschrift angibt,
so nach dem Motto, äh, Lokal XY, dann müsste das im Hintergrund noch ein Reverse-Lockup
machen, wie ist denn die Straße dazu, äh, die Karte aktuell sitze ich noch nicht, die
aktuell sitze ich erst on safe, auf safe geht grad nicht, also, sagen wir jetzt mal
hier, ok, was hatte ich hier, Zeil, Zeil 2, Frankfurt, so, bam, nimmt er, passt, so, und
das geht aktuell über die Google, über die Google Places, ähm, heißt das glaub ich,
AP, Google Places Autocomplete, äh, werden die Daten nur einmal übertragen oder werden
die dynamisch auf jedem Such, suchen und so weiter vom Server geholt, äh, ich proxy das
aktuell durch, durch unser Backend durch, also sprich, unser Backend kriegt die Anfrage
und geht dann zu Google und, äh, cached rudimentär Anfragen, zwischen, nämlich mit, äh, dem,
dem von, es gibt für.NET ne Polly, das ist, äh, so ein, so ein Extension für den HTTP-Kline,
ähm, der kann auch ein bisschen Caching, aber nur sehr rudimentär, super advanced Geschichten
cache der nicht, ähm, und Google APs sind Schweine teuer, wieso nimmst du nicht gleich
Google Maps, weil Google Maps erstens, was ich ein bisschen doof finde, dass man den
AP-Key im Frontend hinterlegen muss, was aber kein Problem ist, da hat Google schon vorgesorgt,
man kann das ganze sperren lassen und so, das funktioniert, also dass es dann wirklich
nur von der gewünschten Stelle ausgeht, ähm, aber Google Maps funktioniert so richtig
gut eigentlich nur mit Google Maps, och Gott, ist Unity Media wieder abkacken? Ne, geht
eigentlich gerade, äh, Google Maps funktioniert halt so richtig gut nur mit Google Zeug und
wir machen weder die Routenberechnung, noch, äh, die Distanz-AP oder andere Sachen über
Google, einfach weil Google APs ziemlich teuer sind, ich hab mir schon überlegt, ob wir
nicht Mapbox nehmen in Zukunft, ähm, aber Google APs sind relativ teuer, man kriegt
bei Google, glaub, 300 Euro oder so oder 200 Euro, also du hast ein relativ hohes, ähm,
gratis-Kontingent, aber an sich verbraucht man da schon ganz schön viel und spätestens
wenn man drüber rausgeht über das gratis-Kontingent wird's teuer, ich hab allein beim entwickeln
und nur mit dieser Autocomplete-AP, beim entwickeln, hab ich, glaub ich, jetzt schon 20 Euro,
äh, 20 Dollar von meinem virtuellen Konto bei Google, also sprich von meinem Bonusguthaben
weg, nur beim entwickeln und Autocomplete ausprobieren, 20 Dollar weg, ja, genau, also
Verlauf, Notizen, klar, kann man machen, wunderbar, kann anschauen, ob man einen Wartungsvertrag
hat oder nicht, man kann Text flaschen und so, so, ähm, jetzt kommen wir mal zum eigentlichen
Feature, ähm, also wir haben jetzt hier die Leute hinzugefügt, äh, übrigens hier Mike
Krabbe, Mike Krabbe möchte auch unbedingt noch einen Besuch abgestattet kriegen, so,
und jetzt hat man die, wie man hier gesehen hat, hinzugefügt, sprich, die Kunden haben
hinzugefügt und jetzt lassen wir mal ne Route berechnen, wenn man jetzt hier auf diesen
Route berechnungs, diese Art Warenkorb-Dings geht, zack, dann kommt man auf das, äh, was
ist denn das hier, warum hört er die Karte einfach auf, ähm, zumindest kommt man auf
eine Karte raus, wo man schon mal an sieht, ah, ich weiß warum, ich weiß warum daneben
ne Nücke ist, ich hatte vorhin ne Leafland-Plugin ausprobiert, was einem die Route als, als Vorschau
hier nebenan zeigt, also sprich, erste Station Frankfurt, zweite Station, das dritte Station,
das vierte Station ist, deswegen, ich glaube, habe ich die Karte noch nicht richtig eingerückt,
so, und was man hier schön sieht ist, das ist jetzt die Route, die er berechnet hat,
optimal um die ganzen Kunden anzufahren, und zwar, wir fahren los von Frankfurter Main,
dann fahren wir hier lang, so, dann fahren wir hier, der erste Kunde kommt dann in Lauben,
der nächste kommt in Oberostendorf, dann kommt der nächste in Jesenwang, Steinhörig, was
es nicht alles für Dörfer gibt, ähm, Eiting, und dann gehts hier weiter hoch nach Gzeses,
und dann nach Chemnitz, und dann nach Nienhagen, und dann wieder zurück nach Frankfurt, so,
und das ist nicht die optimalste Route, weil die optimalste Route an sich gibt es ja nicht,
ähm, oder ich so ohne weiteres, aber das ist eine recht optimale Route, so, und das macht
er im Hintergrund halt, das ist eine ziemlich lange Tour, ja, und das macht er im Hintergrund
halt für die ganzen, ganzen Sachen, aber ich kanns, ich kanns ja mal zeigen, wir können
auch mal ein bisschen, ich weiß übrigens nicht, wo das Maximum ist, wir fügen jetzt einfach
noch mal jede Menge Leute hinzu, ups, wir fügen jetzt einfach noch mal jede Menge Leute hinzu
und gucken, ob das Ganze dann funktioniert, ähm, 13, ach komm, wir gucken, ohne Scheiß,
ich gucke mal wie viel funktioniert, ich weiß nicht wie viel funktioniert, ich hab's noch
nie ausprobiert, also 23 Schaltepunkte, bäm, geht, huge Routenberechnung, es ist so voll,
dass man noch nicht bei den ganzen, dass man das überhaupt sieht, so man sieht jetzt schon,
die Routenberechnung wird ein wenig komplizierter, wo passiert die Routenberechnung, ähm, aktuell
nicht bei uns auf dem System, aber, ähm, wir benutzen ne Kombination aus, ähm, OpenStreetMaps,
OpenStreetMaps Routing, diese OpenStreetMaps Routing Maschinen und ein weiteres Open Source
Projekt von GitHub, weil das sehr viele Sachen kann, was beispielsweise Google Maps nicht
kann, was zum Beispiel die Google Routing API nicht kann, ist, ähm, untimedia, was
die Google Routing API nicht kann, ist, ähm, Zeitfenster, also sprich, du kannst, die Google
hat zwar so ne Route Optimization API, aber was man nicht machen kann ist, dass man sagen
möchte, hey, ähm, ich muss um 5 Uhr da sein und um 8 Uhr da, das könnte ja Einfluss
auf die Route haben und im Zweifelsfall sorgt es auch dafür, dass es überhaupt nicht möglich
ist, wenn man sagt, hey, du kannst nicht da sein und ne Stunde später da, die Route funktioniert
überhaupt nicht, ähm, das Open Source Tool kann das, und das ist ne Mischung aus der,
aus OpenStreetMaps, der OpenStreetMaps, dieser OpenStreetMaps Routing Maschinen und einem
weiteren Open Source Tool, was die, das Routing für uns macht, sollte das nicht ordentlich
funktionieren, wir können immer jederzeit umsteigen auf, äh, Google Maps und, äh, Google.
Sag mal, hängt bei euch das Trieb auch manchmal, obwohl ich nicht keine Paketverluste oder sonst
was hab?
Ja, das ist das, was wir grade, was wir grade programmieren.
Mehr gibt's da ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht zu zeigen.
Termin und Berichte gibt's noch nix.
Ähm, ja, dann mach ich jetzt mal wieder zu.
So, da sind wir schon n bisschen dran, seit, seit ne Woche oder so, oder zwei Wochen.
Aber wir machen halt nicht so viel dran, nehmen wir mal wieder n bisschen.
Also, ich denke, ich denke, das wird ganz nett.
Ähm, er hat das dem Typ viel zu billig verkauft, aber insofern find ich's nicht schlecht, wenn
es quasi das erste, das erste Projekt zu unserer, unserer Kollaboration ist, ähm, und vor allem,
nachdem ich absolut keine Erfahrung mit Routing habe und solche Dinger zu betreiben, ist
es nicht verkehrt, wenn derjenige, der das benutzt, am Ende da auch n bisschen kooperativer
ist, als jemand, der permanent auf den Sack geht, wenn's nicht funktioniert.
So, ok, ähm, gucken wir mal, ob das Tool meine Fragen, die Fragen mitgelockt hat.
Ah, sehr schön, guck mal hier.
Also, Global Twitchy Monster, kennst du eine Software, die virtuelle Maschine, wobei wir
gehen erstmal noch mal kurz das durch, was, was damit, was mit dem, mit dem, äh, Tool,
was ich gerade gezeigt hab, zu tun hat.
Ähm, hat die Seite ein Responsive Design, ja, ja, hab ich jetzt nicht gezeigt, wo hostet
ihr das?
Auf ner eigenen Kiste.
Aber nicht bei uns, sondern, äh, halt gemietet, ja.
Aktuell läuft's bei Digital Ocean, aktuell läuft's bei Digital Ocean auf ner poplischen,
äh, zwei Kern, zwei Kern und, und 8G oder so, VM, einfach weil's die einfachste Sache
war.
So, ähm, schönes Projekt, muss los, ja, danke, nice, also, hat Responsive Design auf, ich
kann, ich kann jetzt zeigen, so ungefähr, wie's aussieht, Beautify Data Table, die kriegen
Zugang da drauf, ja, so ist das geplant, da muss ich das nicht selbst hosten, ähm, also,
die, man kann sich das ungefähr so vorstellen, wie die Tabelle aussieht, wenn das Fenster
klein genug wird, dann switch die Tabelle in so nen, in so nen View hier, also das ist,
das ist so weit responsive, wie's funktioniert.
Wie kein Container, vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht, ja, aber, für so kleinen Kram
bringt's das nicht so wirklich, weil, du musst ja dein Containerzeug irgendwo drauf laufen
lassen.
Und da kannst du dir, ich meine, klar, du kannst da nen Kubernetes in Azure holen, aber wozu
für eine Sache?
Vielleicht lassen wir das auch in nem Container laufen später, ähm, aber wir brauchen ja
noch ein bisschen mehr, das heißt, ich fänd's schon, ich fänd's schon ganz cool, wenn
wir das auf nem eigenen Leadungssurfer laufen lassen können, weil, ähm, auf den Leadungssurfer
muss ja noch das ganze OpenStreetMap, OpenStreetMaps drauf, OpenStreetMaps Routing und das, ähm,
OpenSource-Programm für, für Routenberechnung.
Das kommt allerdings in Container, oder ist teilweise schon in Container und ich könnte
mir vorstellen, dass wir es auch so machen werden, dass wir dann pro Domain, beziehungsweise
pro, wie auch immer es dann benutzen sollte, ob das überhaupt was wird, steht hier eh
noch in den Sternen, ja, müssen wir mal gucken, was da rauskommt am Ende, ähm, dass wir da
in den eigenen Container machen, ja, wahrscheinlich sogar, wahrscheinlich sogar, aktuell läuft
das Deployment über GitHub Actions, das ist sehr praktisch, deswegen haben wir uns das
auch letztens im Stream angeguckt, das ist sehr praktisch, ich push das einfach bei uns
in Master Branch ins Git und da dauert's zweieinhalb Minuten, dann baut er das Projekt auf GitHub
als, äh, Standalone.NET Core Projekt und als, äh, Frontend, Vue Frontend, äh, Vue
Formel Projekt und SCPs auf den Server rüber und startet den Server neu, also den, den
Dienst neu, nicht den ganzen Server, das heißt, ich muss einfach nur Master pushen
und dann funktioniert's, ok, also, hat die Seite ein responsive design benutzt, das haben
wir geklärt, kannste einfach, dass die Kunden direkt sehen, was das ist, das ist eine gute
Idee, äh, warte mal, hat das irgendwas übersehen, ah, nee, hier, das wollte ich eh noch beantworten,
kennst, nee, kannst du ein Tool, um Backend Calls während der Frontend Entwicklung zu
machen, also, ich mein, ich hab jetzt alles lang gedauert, bis ich dann auf Comments,
ehrlich gesagt nicht so wirklich, äh, ich hab die Frage auch am Anfang erst falsch
gelesen, ich hab das so interpretiert, weil ich grade erzählt hab, wo es um Fake, Fake
Daten Genetierung geht, ich hab das am Anfang gelesen, wie Fake Daten Genetierung, willst
du ja gar nicht, willst keine Fake Daten generieren, willst quasi Fake Antworten haben von deinem
Backend, also quasi, du willst gar kein Backend haben, du willst so tun, als hättest du nen
Backend, oder, im Zweifelsfall, ähm, nen, nen, nen Mini Backend, wo du ihm sagst, gib
Fake Zeug zurück, ähm, ehrlich gesagt, nee, ich habe aber letztens, äh, irgendwo mal
nen Webcast geguckt, ich guck ja immer abends so auf'm Tablet, irgendwo nen, wow, Webcast
geguckt, da hat einer was erzählt zu, ähm, was war das, das, was war das, was war das,
das könnte das sogar gewesen sein, oder, ich glaube, das war das, ich glaube, das war
das, hm, bin ich mir jetzt immer sicher, ob das das gewesen ist, hab ich aber noch nix
mitgemacht, Jess funktioniert oder, mag sein, ähm, ich hab's nicht ausprobiert, ich hab
nur letztens ein Video zu geguckt, ich glaube, das war das, ähm, wo er irgendwie gezeigt
hat, dass er quasi, dass er quasi Backend Calls macht, ohne nen Backend zu haben, äh,
es wär auf jeden Fall interessant zu wissen, also, falls du was findest, sag ruhig, noch
mal Bescheid, würde mich auch interessieren, ich hab's leider, sonst hätt ich dich gar
nicht so lange jetzt auf irgendeine Antwort warten lassen, ähm, ich hab's am Anfang falsch
interpretiert, nämlich mit Fake-Daten generieren, sonst hätt ich gleich was dazu gesagt, ähm,
es gibt, eins muss man ja sagen, was heute in Javascript aktuell ist, ist morgen in Javascript
schon wieder out, aber trotzdem gibt es viele coole neuen Sachen in Javascript, ich hab
beispielsweise letztens was gefunden, ähm, was hast du gefunden letztens, ist schon ein
bisschen länger her, ähm, gibt's auch schon, gibt's auch schon drei Jahre oder so, ähm,
es ist eine Library, wie man quasi blockende Aktion im, im, im UI unblockend machen kann,
weiß nicht, wie ich das anders erklären soll, also sprich, wenn man beispielsweise den Array
hat, was man sortieren will, oder filtern will, ähm, hier mal zum Beispiel, da gibt's ja
die Möglichkeit, also aktuell hast du, hast du, du hast drei Varianten, wie du das machen
kannst in, in Javascript, entweder, du machst das, du machst, machst das synchron, dann
plockt, dann plockt dein GUI, das funktioniert nicht standardlich, nö, wenn du Array sort
machst in Javascript, dann plockt dir dein ganzes GUI, bis fertig sortiert ist, weil
Event Loop grab, na was heißt grab, an sich ist so funktioniert der Kram halt, ja, die
zweite Variante, ist asynchron zu machen, sind Web-Worker, das ist quasi, da können
wir auch mal ein Beispiel zu machen, da gibt es auch von Mozilla ein gutes, gutes Beispiel,
die zweite Variante sind Web-Worker, das ist so eine Art Multithreading im Browser, so
eine Art, ja, es ist ein bissl, bissl hässlicher, wie, äh, ordentliches Multithreading in einer
ordentlichen Programmiersprache, aber, Moment, die mein ich gar nicht, die haben, die haben
schön, schönes Tutorial, aber das funktioniert ganz gut, das funktioniert ganz gut, man muss
ein eigenes Javascript-File anlegen, was dann quasi nichts anderes macht, also man legt
ein eigenes Javascript-File an, was dann von einem Background-Thread ausgeführt wird und
zwischen MainThread und, also zwischen UI-Thread und Background-Thread macht man hier mit PostMessage,
schickt mal Aufgaben hin und her, das ist relativ easy, ehrlich gesagt, und da kann
man, ähm, einen Background-Worker machen, der quasi hier wartet auf OnMessage und dem
postet man dann vom Frontend aus, sag mal, einen Array mit 5000, 5000, ähm, Einträgen,
lässt ihn sortieren und der postet das zurück an den MainThread und der MainThread sagt
in seiner OnMessage, äh, äh, Funktion, Methode, äh, a ist da, ich bind es jetzt ins Frontend
ein, also das ist die erste Variante, wie man was, und ich finde mit die sauberste Variante,
wie man was asynchron in, in Javascript machen kann, über Web-Worker, äh, ein bissl doof
ist es, wie auch generell bei allen Multithreading-Geschichten, wenn das, was man hin und her schiebt, recht
groß ist, da muss man sich fragen, inwieweit das was bringt, also wenn man da jetzt irgendwie
einen, einen, einen Array hat aus, keine Ahnung, 50.000 Javascript-Objekten und das schickt,
das schickt man da rein, sortiert es und schiebt es wieder zurück, vielleicht muss man, muss
man gucken, was besser ist, ja, äh, so und die dritte Variante ist, man macht das, ähm,
nach das Sortieren, was normalerweise das UI blockt, macht man in kleine Häppchen, teilt
man in kleine Häppchen auf, also sprich, wenn man einen Array aus 5000 Elementen hat,
was man sortieren möchte, dann sortiert man einfach immer nur in 100er-Schritten und am
Ende halt nochmal einmal drüber und dann blockt das UI auch nicht, wenn man schnell genug
ist, beziehungsweise wenn man es in klein genug Häppchen macht, so und das ist eklig,
sowas von Hand zu programmieren, da muss man nämlich ganz viel Zeit und Geschiss machen
und da, da ist, da zeigt Javascript wieder sich von der komplett hässlichen Seite und
das Ding ist echt praktisch, das macht das nämlich für einen, wenn man jetzt einen Array,
äh, filtern will, also sprich nach Elementen, die in ein gewisses Kriterium entsprechen,
da kann ich einfach sagen, hier erst einen Filter, schieb hier meinen Array rein, steck
ich meinen Array rein mit 50.000 Elementen und der macht dieses ganze Set Timeout und
Async Zeug für mich und am Ende krieg ich einen fertig gefilterten Results Array raus,
was ich da weiter verwenden kann, das ist wirklich praktisch, äh, so einfach sei ich
dich ja gut, die Variante hab ich jetzt gar nicht, gar nicht erwähnt, das geht natürlich
auch, das ist ja logisch, das ist klar, das ist, äh, nie verkehrt, sauberseitig kann
man es auch machen, ist wahrscheinlich sogar die schönste Variante von allen, sorgt nämlich
auch dafür, dass man das auf irgendwelchen kack Android-Telefonen machen kann, die,
oder auf älteren iPhones, die halt nicht alles unterstützen, geschweige denn so viel
Power haben, da irgendwie im Frontend ruckelfrei 50.000 Elemente zu sortieren, Pränup, das
ist ne gute Idee, ich würd's eigentlich prinzipiell sauberseitig machen, ich find sauberseitig
eigentlich, eigentlich sauberseitig am schönsten, aber sauberseitig, je nachdem was man hat,
kostet mich halt, kostet mich halt Ressourcen, kleinseitig kostet mich nix, und manchmal
ist es halt kleinseitig einfach, einfacher, weil du musst nix hin und her schicken und
nix implementieren, wenn du hast die Daten eh schon da und so ein kurzes Filter ist halt
schnell gemacht, hängt ein bisschen davon ab, was man vor hat, ne, das Streamen hängt
nicht, äh hast du dir die Open-Route-Service-Autor, ja hab ich, hab ich, also erstens Open-Route-Service
selber ist komplett kostenlos, hat aber ne relativ geringe Beschränkung, was man machen
darf, also, nein, äh Platz, die haben nämlich nur, die haben nämlich nur 1000 Geocoding-Requests
am Tag, und ähm, wo fällt denn das Auto, wo fällt denn das Auto-Complete drunter, ich
hab mir das angeguckt, Directions, ist Directions oder Auto-Complete, ich weiß nicht, ich hats
mir angeguckt, es war relativ gering, was man, was man an, an, ähm, Requests zur Verfügung
hat, ähm, das nächste Problem war, dass die Suche nicht gut war, ich hab die Suche mal
ausprobiert von, äh, Open-Street-Maps, Nominatim heißt das bei denen, hab ich die Suche ausprobiert,
und, da hat man, da sieht man mal, äh, hallo, so, wenn man jetzt in deutscher Lesung sucht
nach B, Bär, da würde man eigentlich hoffen, man findet Berlin, aber man findet nicht Berlin,
man findet Bär, Batsch, Bllpp, Bllpp, äh, Bllllpp, findet man, ne.
Ähm, oder in, in Timbuktu, Bär, Tombuktu, Tombuktu, Bär-Tombuktu, Särkle, Timbuktu,
Mali, alles klar, das ist natürlich das was ich finden will, wenn ich nach Bär suche,
und das Ding ist auch nicht besser, wenn man Country auf, äh, Deutschland festlegt,
Dann findet man auch ganz ganz merkwürdige sachen und das problem hat ich mit allen autocomplete api außer google
Gibt es einen import ja es gibt den importen csv import
Das liegt daran weil das einzige format was das tool was die aktuell verwenden das ist irgendso ein
Plotet windows ding mit 30.000 knöpfen dran was die aktuell zur kundendatenverwaltung verwenden
Das einzige was das exportieren kann ist csv und es gibt ein csv import
Aber ich finde den ansatz eh besser dass wir das für die importieren weil dann ist egal in welchem format dann können wir das umfuddeln so dass es funktioniert
Ja
SAP ui 5 ich habe damit noch nie was gemacht klingt aber auf jeden fall eklig
das hatten wir
Kennst du eine software die virtuelle maschinen auf hardware möglich macht die keine hardware virtualisierungen unterstützen ja
Aber das ist nicht schnell also wenn du wirklich wenn du hardcore andere architekturen emulieren willst also zum beispiel wenn du
Arm unter x86 emulieren willst oder sowas dann kannst du kuemo nehmen
Es gibt leute die nehmen kuemo
Lassen darauf den respiren laufen
Und kompilieren sich dann für einen raspberry dinger weil es angeblich schneller wäre das halte ich aber für gerüchte
Die arm emulation in kuemo ist unendlich langsam
Da ist es einfacher man kauft sich ein raspberry pi 4 und lässt dem eine woche laufen bevor das datum vertrat überfertigt aber ja also wenn du wenn du
ein system suchst was was komplett jegliche andere
Architekturen emulieren kann auf einer hardware die es sonst nicht kann
Aber ja also wenn du ein system suchst was was komplett jegliche andere
Dann kuemo, aber wenn es darum geht dass du einfach
Nur
eine x86 vm auf einem x86
System brauchst dann nehmen einfach vmw workstation oder virtualbox
Keines von beiden braucht hardware virtualisierung
Das funktioniert auch ohne
Kvm braucht glaube hardware virtualisierung
Oder braucht kvm
Oder braucht kvm nur hardware virtualisierung für
Pci passt du bin ich mir gar nicht sicher ich glaube ich glaube auch kvm braucht generell hardware virtualisierung
Aber
vor allem workstation sollte
Auch funktionieren ohne hardware virtualisierung die software gibt es ja schon zeiten wo hardware virtualisierung noch nicht funktioniert
Die software gibt es ja schon zeiten wo hardware virtualisierung überhaupt nicht angesagt war
Kvm wir workstation
without
Vtd heißt der kram glaube ich oder vtd
ne
Wie heißt er hinter hardware virtualisierung wie heißt der kram noch mal
Vt vtx
Vt
Ich versuche ein windows framework 64 bit system ohne hardware virtualisierung aufzulassen
Ich musste jetzt das habe ich schon nicht gemacht
Also vor allem workstation müsste prinzipiell funktionieren weil die hat auch das hat auch vor
Lange vor hardware virtualisierung bevor es das überhaupt gab funktioniert
Ausprobieren ich könnte es mal ausprobieren
Wenn ich dem ich meine hardware virtualisierung abschalte aber das kann ich jetzt gerade nicht machen es müsste funktionieren
Aber so wirklich sicher bin ich mir da auch nicht habe ich das habe ich glaube ich noch nie gemacht also seit es 64 bit os gibt und ich 64 bit hab habe ich glaube ich auch hardware virtualisierungen drin
Und alle sagen sap und nicht sap
Was sagst du windows 10 2004 noch nix ich habe es dir noch nicht angeguckt
Was gibt es da neues
Was gibt es denn neues zeig mal her
Äh
Sox sells data ist das ein linux oder ist windows
New court oh
New cortana
Geh weg
Trimula hat recht
Okay also was gibt es noch alles wenn du aus 10 new version of cortana
Microsoft macht sich das leben selbst mal wieder schwer
Na sie haben cortana was ist denn also ich benutze ich benutze cortana überhaupt nicht aber was ist mit microsoft eigentlich wieder los ja
Ich mein jetzt haben sie cortana rausgebracht das war wohl auch ganz gut und hat funktioniert jetzt kann es wieder sachen nicht
Wtf
Was ist mit microsoft?
Ähm zu gucke gar nicht weil ich kein multidisplay setup unter linux habe
Ich habe meine linux vor allem die ist ja logischerweise hier auf einem bildschirm auf dem anderen bildschirm ist ein anderer rechner dran unter windows
Und auf der arbeit habe ich einen curved
curved
4k oder frag mir nicht 32 sonst was toll
Da sind quasi zwei bildschirme in einem das problem habe ich aktuell gar nicht
Einzige was ich mache mit x render am anfang den nordburg bildschirm beim boot den nordburg bildschirm ausschalten
So dann wird cortana auf android ios eingestellt gut das kann ich verstehen ich weiß nicht ob cortana
Auf android ios überhaupt benutzt wurde
Du kannst move und resize cortana windows oder moment das konnte alte cortana nicht
Cortana konnte man nicht resize und das ist jetzt ein krasses neues feature oder was das von cortana resize kann
Okay windows windows halt
Small indy company
Sollten sich mit blizzard zusammen tun dann sind sie vielleicht nicht mehr so so small und indy
Ich sollte sich mit blizzard zusammen tun dann sind sie vielleicht nicht mehr so so small und indy
Ja ja ja wallpaper
Okay, you can set your preference blabla cortana juckt mich ehrlich gesagt nicht die bohne
Finally cortana has improved product productivity skills emails
Wer schreibt noch emails
Erkommene appointments
Gut brauche kein menschen subsystem for linux 2
Windows subsystem
Wir bräuchten eigentlich eher ein linux subsystem for windows dass es mal ordentlich funktioniert
Und wir alles drauf machen können was wir wollen und ein bisschen spiele unter windows verwenden können
Nutzt du virtuelle desktops ja sowohl unter windows wie man hier sieht sowohl unter windows
Als auch unter linux
Überall benutzt virtuelle desktops virtuelle desktops beste
Okay, das finde ich gut dass das neue wsl am start ist
Ich finde es merkwürdig dass man jetzt von einem eher weinartigem ansatz mit quasi
ap übersetzung zu vm gewechselt ist aber wahrscheinlich ist die pflege einfach
Einfach einfacher für microsoft
Es ist gut not not pet improvements ernsthaft
Und
Superleute notebook not pet wird besser ja voll endlich
Line numbers
Boggers
Gibt es auch nicht virtuelle desktops ja das habe ich ja schon oft genug erzählt das einzige was an virtuellen desktops nicht virtuell ist
Ist eigentlich der desktop weil wie ihr seht der desktop ist überall der gleiche
Also not pack in not pet improvement not pet kann jetzt größere schriftarten wahnsinn
Microsoft ist jetzt der innovator schlechthin
Windows search improvements das könnte tatsächlich nicht schlecht sein weil die windows suche ist so
So
So na ja so so geht so aber schön ist die suche nicht
Moment search experience in file explorer ist now powered by windows search moment
heißt das etwa dass wenn ich hier suche
dass nicht die gleiche suche ist die wenn ich hier suche
Was warum
Das war mir überhaupt nicht klar dass das was unterschiedliches ist
Ja anscheinend
Das sind zwei verschiedene das ist typische windows logik
Windows logik na windows ppega am start
Okay an und erholt microsoft das improved search index hat zu reduce impact und performance ja das ist nicht schlecht
Ich weiß übrigens gar nicht warum sich windows also warum sich microsoft so schwer damit tut
um eine ordentliche in der ordentliche suche auf die reihe zu kriegen ich meine unter linux gibt es
Bild in ein paar tools die funktionieren seit 40 jahren
Die sind zwar nicht die absoluten pleading edge tools und es gibt auch bessere sachen
Aber ich meine ein feind hat kein index und durch sucht einfach alles und funktioniert
Und in locate brauchen den index und geht halt
Halt auch einfach es ist nicht das fett die fanciesten tools und haben auch nicht die meisten optionen aber die gehen einfach
Ich verstehe gar nicht das problem
Alternativ gibt es ja auch noch zig weitere varianten für linux was source code suche angeht volltext suche
All möglichen dinger
Ja grepp in kombination vielleicht noch mit dem fuzzy finder es gibt 60.000 varianten und die funktionieren weil es gar nicht was so schwer ist
Da dass wir noch es auf die reihe zu kriegen
Okay sandbox
Sandbox haben wir schon mal ausprobiert finde ich gut dass es jetzt quasi eine offizielle vm lösung gibt die
Für leute die quasi schiss haben sich
Ein virus einzufangen und ich meine die beste lösung ist immer noch
Man hat linux vm
Aber das sowas in windows dabei ist finde ich gut
Aber das finde ich gut
Mein virtual desktops renamen
Okay
Ich hatte bis jetzt ehrlich gesagt wenig bedürfnis meinen desktops zu renamen aber wenn das geht ist gut
Das ist eine winnows vm in windows ja
Task Manager
GPU Temperatures
Ok das ist gut
Disk das ist auch gut
Das sind so Änderungen wo ich mich immer frage
Warum waren die nicht schon vorher lange da
So Sachen die ich selbstverständlich
Erachten würde kommen da immer
Irgendwann rein und es fällt einfach auf
Das konnte Windows ja noch gar nicht
Brauche ich Windows 10 Pro für die Sandbox
Ich weiß es nicht
Ich kann jetzt nicht
Ich kann jetzt Google
Wissen tue ich nicht
Accessibility
Eye Control
Hat das wirklich was mit dem
Auge zu tun
Ok das ist für Leute die wahrscheinlich nicht
mehr richtig die Hände verwenden können
Den Vorleser den verwenden wir auch
Nicht
Den verwenden wir bloß für so Sachen
Das ist der einzige Kram wofür
wir den Ansager verwenden
Und für alle anderen Sachen
verwenden wir
verwenden wir unseren koreanischen Ansager
Das ist mir alles ziemlich wurscht
Was auch immer
Ach das gibt es ein Setting für
Ja endlich
Geh mal fort das will ich ausschalten
Restart
Gibt es das jetzt schon
Das geht mir nämlich immer auf den Sack wenn sich Sachen automatisch starten
Das muss weg
360 Noscope bitte
Moment Moment
Wo habe ich es denn hier
So jetzt haben wir
so alle durch
Ja endlich
Endlich fliegt das alte GUI raus
Was ist mit dem Desktop los
Ganz schön zu lullen Desktop
Sieht mir ja gar nichts drauf
Das würde mal Zeit
Weil aktuell hat ja Windows so zwei Sachen
Das hat Apps
Apps and Features
Und hat
Turn off Windows Features
Total wir
Schau mal nach Corona Virus Challenge
Nein danach schaue ich nicht
Weil ich weiß was das ist
Und da habe ich schon wieder am komplett Verstand der Menschheit
gezweifelt als ich Corona Virus Challenge gesehen habe
Die Corona Virus Challenge
Ist so was für
Die absoluten
Brain Net Zoomer Generation
Die äh
Geht dreht sich darum
Dass man öffentliche Toiletten
Türklinken und Rolltreppen
Griffe ableckt
Das ist die Corona Challenge
Die Leute sind einfach komplett gestört
Das ist
Echt brain dead
Und danach
stecken sie ihre Oma an und die Oma
stirbt und heulen sie rum
Weil sie dumm sind
Welche Linux Distribution
benutzt du Manjaro mit I3WM
Das juckt mich auch nicht
Cloud Download
Plutus und Connect Device juckt mich auch
Network Settings
Network Settings Page
Okay zeig mal her
Alter Microsoft was ist mit euch los
Hier kann man immer noch nichts einstellen
Man kann immer noch nichts einstellen
Das juckt mich doch überhaupt nicht
Was ist das Schwachsinn
Typisches
Microsoft GUI hier
Warum Manjaro nicht direkt
einstellen muss
Weil Manjaro einen ordentlichen Installer hat
Und weil Manjaro die Repos
2-3 Wochen ein bisschen
zwischenbuffert und man nicht den
allerletzten krassen Bleeding Edge Scheiß abbekommt
Das wäre gut wenn Windows
mehrere Monitore mit unterschiedlicher
Refresh Rate ordentlich könnte
Ich bilde mir aber schon, ich bilde mir ein, dass das schon seit Jahren geht
Weil ich hatte mal
meine Capture Card dran
am zweiten Display Ausgang
mit 60 FPS
Und der Haupt Bildschirm
lief auf 144, das hat funktioniert
Mouse Cursor Settings
Ein neues Ibu
Cow Moji
Aha
Jetzt kann man Cow Moji verwenden
Uvo, Ovo
Was?
Dictator Support
Was da los
Da soll man in Nordkorea bleiben
Was?
Oh mein Swift Key
Ist Swift Key nicht das zusätzliche
Das zusätzliche
Detroit Keyboard
Das habe ich auf
Amazon Tablet
Das ist jetzt Microsoft
Okay
Na dann
Das war's
Okay, man muss sagen, es tut sich nicht viel
Was mich
interessieren würde ist, ob Windows
10 2004
Also Windows 10 2004
Eine sehr unglückliche Versionsbezeichnung
muss man sagen in dem Fall
Das Windows 10 2004
Ist das wieder so eine
Neuinstallation unter der Haube
Oder ist das ein Update
Ich hoffe, das ist ein Update
Weil bei einer Neuinstallation
unter der Haube muss ich wahrscheinlich
wieder mein gesamtes System entschlüsseln
und neu verschlüsseln
darauf
Wobei es letztens
Letztes Vollinstallation Update
hat es mit der Verschlüsselung funktioniert
ohne dass ich es entschlüsseln musste
Ja
Was haben wir noch für Fragen
Habe ich denn übersehen hier?
Task Name, was?
Ich meine von wegen Automatisierung
meine ursprüngliche Frage
Äh
Weiß ich jetzt nicht mehr
Italien, ich hoffe, dass wir aus Italien bestellen
Das war mal Big Brain Move
Hatten wir?
Das ist noch nicht ganz klar
was alles reinkommt
beziehungsweise wie man es überhaupt umsetzen kann
Wir haben keine Straßennamen
Solange es eine richtig echte Adresse ist
dann funktioniert das
Ja
Ich war auch auf der Seite drauf
und ich habe nicht genau gecheckt um was es ging
Das einzige was ich verstanden habe ist
dass es ein Projekt ist
quasi ein Programmiereprojekt
wo man Projekte
vorschlagen kann
oder
was denn das
Was zum?
Was ist das?
Ich habe einen Mauszeige Highlighter
installiert
unter Linux
Ich wusste bis heute gar nicht mal, dass ich
Ich kann mich dran erinnern, ich habe das mal installiert
Ihr
Windows Taster C
Hier habe ich mal installiert, weil ich mir gedacht habe
wenn ich mal Streams aufnehme
und man Sachen zeigen will
dann kann man Highlighten
Guck Leute hier
was eigentlich ganz praktisch ist
habe ich komplett vergessen wieder
Hier geht es wohl darum, dass man
Projekte programmiert
die wohl
gerade bei Corona
die die Bevölkerung gut unterstützen
aber so ganz habe ich nicht gecheckt
warum es dabei ging
Die Bundesregierung startet
hackathon gegen Corona
Darf man da nicht Corona sagen oder muss man es irgendwie cooler aussprechen?
Corona oder so
Oder wie letztens auf Twitter
getrenntet ist
Corona Virus
mit Virus
Ich muss mal gucken,
dass ich übrigens keine Subs verpasst habe
Brick hat gesubbt, Dankeschön
falls ich es übersehen habe
Schrödingers hat gesubbt, Ander hat gesubbt
Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs Leute
Heftiges Hackerbild
Was hat er denn auf?
Ich würde das Bild gerne groß machen und gucken
Ah, yes, alles klar, jetzt erkenne ich sofort was er auffallt
Alles klar
Ich erkenne auch nicht mal ob es Windows ist
Ich meine von der Taskbar hier unten könnte es Windows sein, aber
Das Corona, das klingt da richtig beknackt
Hauptsache Pion Pizza
Vor allem hat er eine Tastatur
eine Mini Tastatur
Niemand
würde das so machen
das aussehen eine ganze Tastatur an
Du machst die Hände vom Außen Tastatur weg
futterst was, putzt sie kurz ab
und machst weiter, ansonsten
flutscht ja gleich nach 5 Minuten Tastatur
Genau, also
Man kann das irgendwo einreichen
Ich frage mich jetzt, was da rausgekommen ist
oder ob das jetzt noch, das startet jetzt nicht am nächsten
Hier, hat gestartet
YouTube Channel
Alle Herausforderungen
Wir wollen es aber wissen
Wie kommunizieren wir mit dem
Ja und weiter
Wie kommunizieren wir den Status
in Supermärkten
Das ist tatsächlich eine gute Frage
Wie kriegt man das auf die Reihe
Dass man bevor man hingeht weiß was verfügbar ist
Da müssen aber die Supermärkte mitmachen
Krankenhäusern
Wie können die Kap, was die Kapazitäten
hat, auch eine interessante Frage
Wie können wir kreativ werden in Seiten von
Social Distancing, da wollten wir uns doch
ganz am Anfang mal das hier angucken
Das Social Distancing Dashboard
Also sprich, da sieht man wie gut
die Leute distanzt sind
Heute bisher Trends
Oh nice
Die Leute sind viel distanzierter
Covid Companion App
Ok, da haben jetzt 30
Milliarden Sachen was vorgeschlagen
Ja, habe ich vor einer Weile gesehen
Und da war es für mich recht unsichtig, um was es da geht
Aber mittlerweile ist es
Eigentlich klar
Aber ich habe da immer nicht so Energie mich in sowas einzubringen
Ok, was machen die da so
Typisches Neuland-Internet ey
Typisches Neuland-Internet
Ist das nicht peinlich
Ich mein ok, es geht ja um was gemeinnütziges
Ok, ich will nicht mich zu sehr flamen, aber
Was soll ich jetzt angucken
144p
Das Schlimme ist ja, das ist ein 720p
Achso, du meinst Baldea
Ach, keine Ahnung
Was sahen die anderen Videos auch alle so aus?
Ne, da sieht es doch normal aus
Kommt dazu
Ist zwar auch nicht absolut High-End Technik, aber
Das ist
Mit euch
Und deswegen dauert es gerade noch ein bisschen
Zu viele Grills am Start
Naja, die Quali, die andere Quali
Ist auch nicht so viel, nicht so viel besser
Achso, das ist auch nicht so gut
Achso, die andere Quali ist auch nicht so viel, nicht so viel besser
Was ist denn das für ein Chat-Tool
Das ist irgendwie
Slack
Ne, keine Ahnung was das ist
Hangouts
Das ist Hangouts
Das, das haben wir mal
Dass man immer noch Hangouts verwendet
Hangouts haben wir vor
Vor 10 Jahren verwendet auf YouTube manchmal
Hast du eigentlich noch
Deine Ducky-Mon-Tastatur? Klar, verwende ich auf der Arbeit
Jeden Tag
Mal kurz gucken
Ob es hier in Österreich
In Österreich noch Klopapier zu bestellen gibt
Regina
Klopapier, yes
Innerhalb 3 Wochen
Deren Slack hat aktuell 22.000 User
Boah, nicht schlecht
Ihr müsst eine Tastatur mitbringen, nö, müssen wir nicht
Aber die Tastaturen, die wir bekommen
sind nicht so doll, deswegen habe ich
mir eine eigene Tastatur mitgebracht
Was haben wir sonst noch, da haben wir gerade schon
DM, schick nicht nach Deutschland
Und im deutschen TM-Shop
Gibt es wahrscheinlich nichts mehr, ha?
Lieferzeit ist aber an der Zeit nicht
lieferbar
Warum kaufen die eigentlich alle wie verrückt
Toilettenpapiere
Dir bleibt hier gerade nichts anderes übrig
Mit zu machen
Nice day
Nicht verfügbar
Pfirsichpohr, feuchtes Toilettenpapier
Ah, yes
Wenn man es braucht
Noch wenige Stück verfügbar
Liefern die auch noch Deutschland
Ist ganz schön teuer
Arbeit so mit Docker und so
Karo auf der Arbeit, ja
Mach ich, kann man nach Deutschland bestellen?
Oh, Grip
Nee, doch nicht
Zur Kassa
Sagt man das in Österreich so?
Geht nach Deutschland?
Ah
Geht anscheinend nicht
Na toll
Kennst du das Video, wo der Opa
den ganzen Schlecker leer kauft?
Nee, hast du mal Link?
Ich hab noch nie mit Apis gearbeitet
Wie würde ich eine
Beispielsweise PHP
mit Beispielsweise Java
verbinden?
Äh, über HTTP? Ganz einfach
Apis sind ja nichts anderes
wie ganz normale Webaufrufe
wie ganz normale HTTP-Aufrufe
Nur halt nach einem gewissen Schema
sodass es für die Daten, die man hat, logisch ist
Was streit beim Hamsterkauf?
Okay, okay, Moment, Moment, Moment
Das müssen wir uns jetzt mal angucken
Streit beim Hamsterkauf
Wow, die schreien da schon voll rum
Oh, die schreien da schonrum
Ich frag mich, was pile-ja
die wollen grad, ich wollt auch gerade, ich frag mich,
wo ils stmet
die
St mot
des
aber
auch
ich wollte auch krass... ich frag mich,was passiert wenn man Zombie anrückt
aieiei
– Lithemusik –
Fuck... Die drehen ja voll am rad
Die drehen ja vall am rad
Du hast ein anderes geschickt?
Ja, du hast ein Video von 2012 geschickt.
Die tränen ja voller Brat, ey.
Ist du bekloppt oder was?
Scheiße, Alter. Die sind ja voll am eskalieren.
Was geht mit denen ab, Alter? Das ist ja nicht mal normal.
Also wer heutzutage jetzt gerade im Supermarkt arbeitet, ey, der hat echt die Arschkarte.
Alter.
Ich finde es ja auch geil, wie die, ne?
Keiner traut sich was zu sagen.
Das ist so geil, ne?
Es traut sich keiner was zu sagen und danach, wenn die Situation wieder geklärt ist,
ähm, jetzt sprechen sie aber mal ein Hausverbot aus.
Das können sie sich aber so nicht bieten lassen.
Sprechen sie mal ein Hausverbot aus.
Was Spasten, Alter? Auf voller Linie alles Spasten.
Die einzige, die mir echt leid tut, ist, ähm, die Frau, die in dem Supermarkt arbeitet.
Eine Güte.
Deswegen, Leute, macht so wie ich, also in dem einen Fall, also generell macht es nicht so wie ich,
aber in dem Fall Klopapier macht es wie ich, kauft den Kram im Internet bei irgendeinem Großhändler.
Dann habt ihr zwar einen riesen Haufen Klopapier, aber ich meine, so what?
Ihr braucht eh Klopapier. Klopapier ist nichts, was irgendwie schlecht wird.
Und selbst wenn ihr ein bisschen zu viel Klopapier habt, ist auch kein Bild,
ähm, dann habt ihr halt für ein halbes Jahr Klopapier, wenn ihr euch so ne, wenn ihr euch
paar Rollen beschaut, ne?
Und es ist viel einfacher zu planen, zu liefern, alles, wenn man das online bestellt.
Schaut ihr das andere Video auch noch an.
Okay.
Was sind das andere Videos? Das andere Video, das hier.
Das ist aber von 2012, das ist schon alt.
Ausnahmezustand am Morgen in dieser Schleckerfiliale in der Wilhelmsdorfer Straße.
Das Rentner e-Partile kauft den Laden leer.
Das ist von 2012 an.
An die 100 Packungen Toilettenpapier und Küchenrollen werden gehamstert.
Boah, was geht mit denen ab, ey?
Der Lager wird geblündert. Die Kunden seht heiß, scharf auf den Rappen.
Das Lager wird geblündert. Die Kunden seht heiß, scharf auf den Rappen.
Schlangen bilden sich vor dem Geschäft. Nicht alle dürfen gleichzeitig rein.
Viele Kunden müssen warten, bis sie an die begehrte Ware rankommen.
Dann gibt es kein Halten mehr.
Alles wird gekauft, weil es billig ist.
Da würde ich nie mitmachen bei so einem Scheiß, äh.
Ich kauf eh generell sau, also sau wenig in Läden ein.
Ich bestelle das meiste online und immer wenn ich es brauche.
Ey, man, jetzt ein paar Klopapier bleibt mir nix, das soll übrig.
Ganze Toilettenpapier im Laden gebunkert.
Nun will er auch noch an die Lagerbestände ran.
Seine Frau soll helfen.
20 Pakete Küchenrollen, 20 Pakete noch dazu.
Oh, was geht ab, ey?
Nee, mich kannst du mit Videos nicht rickrollen, weil ich hab in meinem Chat einen Vorschau,
äh, was hinter YouTube-Videos steckt.
Das heißt, ich kann wieder rickrollt werden.
Richtig, noch kann ich debattet werden mit Monkrat-Tost-Videos.
Und dann holen Sie sich jetzt ein Taxi oder was?
Naja, klar.
Dann bezahle ich für die Karre von hier bis hier rüber nach Hause.
3,50 Mark, den liebe ich. 10 Mark und Stunde sind die da offen.
Ist das fake?
Oder ist das echt?
Viele hab ich nicht mehr, das sind die letzten 24.
Habst du ein anderer Toilettenpapier?
Andere Toilettenpapier haben wir auch hier.
Sechs müssen noch hoch, da 30 sind.
Und 20 sind mal Küchenrollen.
Egal, welche Sorte.
Das ist scheiß egal, das ist auf Ihren Arsch.
WTF, was das für ein Spaß hat.
Ohje, hier ist eine Axte drin, hat sie gesagt.
Das ist das Küchenrollen.
Na ja, pack da hier oben hin, da kommt wieder was hin.
Ich mein, der hat's gut.
Der hat bestimmt noch Klopapier von damals übrig heute, wenn er noch lebt.
Wenn der Taktifahrer Katastrophen hat, ist er zwanzig.
Ich muss das wie immer fahren.
Die Stimme von dem Typ erinnert mich an irgendwas.
An irgendwas erinnert mich der...
Ha.
Ich weiß nicht.
Haben Sie denn noch Platz zu Hause?
Kommt doch in den Keller runter.
Das reicht doch für den ganzen Jahr, dann bräuchte er nicht in den Kuchen gehen.
Jetzt weiß ich...
Jetzt weiß ich, wie der anhört.
Der hört sich...
Frag nicht, warum ich so Videos kenne.
Der hört sich wie der Klatscheier-Typ an.
Kennt den Scheiß noch jemand?
Nein, es ist kein Toss-Video.
Es ist aber eigentlich ein ziemlich dämliches Video.
Das war vor ein paar Jahren, da ist es...
Da erzählt er an irgendeinem Typ von Klatscheier.
Richtig dämlich.
Das müsst ihr auf YouTube suchen.
Richtig dumm.
Es ist weder Toss noch sonst was, aber eigentlich richtig dämlich.
Ja gut, aber...
Der Opa kauft halt...
Der Opa kauft halt einen Schlecker leer.
Ist doch gut, kann er doch machen.
Der hat halt heute noch Klopapier.
Ist doch gut für ihn.
Da braucht er jetzt kein Klopapier mehr.
Soll ich das neue Doom raus?
Soll ich das...
Soll ich das neue Doom mittlerweile raus?
Ah, seit gestern.
Da weiß ich doch, was ich spielen kann dann.
Nice.
Oh, ich muss euch mal den bescheuertsten...
Wartet mal, ich hab einen ultra dämlichen Aluhut-Kommentar.
Unter YouTube entdeckt.
Den muss ich euch mal zeigen.
Ich muss den bloß gerade mal auf meinem Handy suchen.
Warum sagt man eigentlich immer noch Handy?
Hier.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich den finde.
Das ist der Aluhut-Preiskommentar aller Zeiten.
Mist.
Finde ich nicht.
Dann lese ich es euch vor, weil ich hab's nur...
So blöd wie ich bin, ich hab's nur gescreenshotted.
Und das war ein Video, wo es mal wieder um das beliebte Thema Klimawandel ging.
Das ist ja so ein Thema, da sind mittlerweile...
Sobald da auf YouTube ein Video zu kommt, da hast du...
Schlagen sich die Leute die Köppe ein.
Und ich find's immer ganz lustig, teilweise was da für Leute auftauchen.
Muss ich euch mal vorlesen.
Wie gesagt, ich hab nur einen Screenshot von...
Also bisschen Kontext.
Das war wohl ein Video.
Geht ne Stunde 33, ich war hier bei 11 Minuten.
Irgendwas von den Grünen oder so.
Keine Ahnung, ich erkenne den Videotitel nicht mehr.
Zumindest, der erklärt uns jetzt hier, der YouTube-Kommentar-Mann.
Der erklärt uns jetzt quasi, wie die Welt funktioniert.
Und zwar...
Es gibt...
Ich lese...
Ich lege auch das nächste Mal vor.
Es gibt keine physikalischen...
Also Zitat, YouTube-Kommentar.
Es gibt keine physikalischen Gesetze.
Nur physikalische Einbildung.
Alles Placebo-Effekt.
Flugzeuge stürzen ab, weil Menschen daran glauben, dass sie abstürzen.
Flugzeuge fliegen, weil Menschen daran glauben, dass sie fliegen.
Das ist genauso wie mit Windows.
Würde die Menschheit sich nicht von Apple veräppeln lassen,
dass ihnen vorgaukelt, dass Windows instabil ist,
würde ein Windows-PC niemals abstürzen.
Das ist alles eine perfide Verschwörung der Wissenschaft.
Apple gleich Newton.
Also Physik gleich der Apfel,
gleich der Adam und Eva aus dem Paradies geworfen hat,
gleich Satan.
Wissenschaft ist also ein Produkt des Teufels,
um die Menschheit zu verführen.
Dabei ist alles so einfach.
Ich glaube, also bin ich.
Glaube ich nicht, bin ich nicht.
Und weg bin ich.
Du Scheiß, Alter.
Ey, ne...
Vielleicht Troll, vielleicht Troll.
Aber wenn du dir die anderen Kommentare angeguckt hast,
unter diesem Video, die waren alle so bescheuert.
Die waren alle so bescheuert.
Ich war früher auch jemand, der immer gesagt hat,
wenn jemand was total abstruktes gepostet hat,
habe ich auch immer gesagt, Troll.
Aber Leute, das können nicht alles Trolle sein.
Da sind legit Posts drunter,
die einfach nur so abwegig für uns sind,
dass wir gar nicht dran glauben können,
dass das wirklich echte Posts sein könnten.
Aber ich fand das schon nicht schlecht.
Mit Apple gleich Newton, Physik der Apfel der Anommete.
Und gleich Satan.
Also Apple gleich der Teufel.
Aber der war ein guter Typ.
Der hat es drauf gehabt.
Die Herleitung war starke.
Deutsch ist YouTube, ich gucke nichts mehr.
Ich gucke nichts mehr.
Ich kann mir kaum was angucken.
Das Einzige, was ich mir in Deutsch...
Nein, stimmt nicht.
Ich gucke mir schon noch ein paar Sachen in Deutsch an.
Aber das Meiste gucke ich mir mittlerweile
international Englisch an.
Ich gucke mir beispielsweise hier auf YouTube
gucke ich mir für Werkzeugtests
gucke ich mir noch manchmal Videos auf Deutsch an.
Von denen hier, die machen das nicht schlecht.
Auch wenn die Videos und Thumbnails
übel nach Clickbait aussehen.
Aber die Videos sind nicht übel.
Und ein paar andere Videos, ein paar andere
deutsche Channels gucke ich mir ab und zu auch noch an.
Aber das Meiste gucke ich mir international YouTube an,
weil ich YouTube Deutschland nicht ertrage.
Und ich blicke nicht mal durch,
was auf YouTube Deutschland so abgeht.
Es gab mal eine Zeit, da kannte ich gefühlt
jeden mit 50k plus Abos.
Heute kriege ich irgendwo was empfohlen
oder irgend einer postet was.
Ich gehe drauf, sehe ein Video von einem Typ,
von dem ich nichts gehört habe.
Und nichts gesehen habe, nicht wusste,
dass er überhaupt auf dieser Welt existiert.
Gehe auf den Channel, 850k Abos.
Wo ich mir denke, den kann es doch nicht erst seit gestern geben.
Ich blicke nicht mal durch auf YouTube.
Aber YouTube Deutschland interessiert mich auch überhaupt nicht.
Meiste Trash Videos, ja, ist so.
Mal gucken, ob wir den Fragen hier irgendwann hinterher kommen.
Hatten wir?
Ah, Big Brain.
Ist das so ein Tick von dir? Ja, ja.
Habe ich schon.
Hatten wir auch schon.
Mit Sicherheit sind da welche dabei.
Weil es gibt ja auch immer noch Leute, die der Meinung sind,
dass Corona generell nur reiche, weiße Männer betrifft.
Hatten wir auch letztens.
Da betrifft es uns schon mal zum größten Teil nicht.
Wir sind wahrscheinlich zum größten Teil weiße Männer,
oder Männer auf jeden Fall, aber reich sind wir nicht.
Also kann es uns schon mal nicht treffen.
Safe, Corona saved. Ganz einfach ist es.
Kennst du eine Möglichkeit, wie man die virtuell
deshalb auf einen Monitor begrenzen kann?
Nee, kenne ich nicht.
Wieso tippst du bei der Uhr immer eine Eins rein?
Ich tippe manchmal sogar Viererblöcke Eins rein.
Wer kann so schnell Einser Viererblöcke tippen, hä?
So.
Was benutzt du zum Verschluss in Bitlocker?
Veracrypt.
Die einzige Software aus Frankreich, die ich glaube je verwendet habe.
Manchmal beantwortest du Fragen kurz, indem du direkt antwortest.
Wir wissen dann aber nicht, weil du...
Ich versuche das meistens vorzulesen, aber es kann sein,
dass ich das manchmal vergesse.
Corona mit der Shotgun, ja, auf geht's.
Also ich bin in einem Team, was schaut, wie man schnellstmöglich
quasi digitale Klassenzimmer digital unterrichtet,
für diese bewerkstelligen kann.
Also ist nicht nur Hacken.
Ah, okay.
Also rein vom Gefühl her, ich bin ja kein so Bauchgefühl.
Ich habe mich ja, ich kenne halt nicht so viele Produkte, aber
ihr wisst, ich bin kein großartiger Microsoft-Fan.
Aber ich glaube, so ad hoc, so das Einfachste,
was man sich aus dem Ärmel schütteln kann,
dürfte tatsächlich Office 365 sein
und Microsoft Teams hosted in Azure.
Das klickt man dreimal und funktioniert.
Ob man jetzt die Microsoft Sachen toll findet,
ist wieder was anderes, aber vom Einfachheits her gerade
sollte das ganz weit oben sein, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Und ihr wisst, ich bin wirklich kein Microsoft-Fan.
Ja, da die Tastatur habe ich noch.
Schneid einfach Küchenrollen in zwei.
Ja, Küchenrollen sind ja auch aus, gibt es ja auch nicht mehr.
Ja, nein.
Die tägliche Aluhut, oh, nee, nee, auf Twitter.
Ich habe echt genug Dappen auf Twitter gehabt die letzten Tage.
Ich könnte mein Klopapier teuer verkaufen auf eBay,
mache ich aber nicht.
Ich habe mir schon überlegt, was ich mit meinem Klopapier mache,
wenn es denn dann ankommt.
Ich stapel meinen Vorratsschrank, so weit wie es geht.
Ich meine, so viele sind das nicht.
690 durch 8 sind 12 Packungen.
Davon werde ich eine Packung dem Nachbar links
und eine Packung dem Nachbar rechts geben.
Was meint ihr, was das für eine Geste, das wird eine Geste sein,
die dafür sorgt, dass sie die nächsten 20 Jahre
meine Pakete von DHL annehmen.
Das ist Vorausschauend für die Zukunft.
Die kriegen einfach beide.
Wer in der heutigen Zeit ein Packen Klopapier verschenkt,
der kann nur gewinnen.
Dann, vielleicht kriege ich auch immer gegrillt,
das vom anderen Nachbar, ja, kann auch sein.
Aber bessere Geste gibt es aktuell nicht.
Das ist quasi das runde Gold, das weiße runde Gold.
Was hälst du von der Aussage, Truecube wäre sicherer,
weil dort ein kompletter Out gemacht wurde?
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber die Umstände über die Schließung von Truecrypt
sind etwas mysteriös, nebulös.
Und VeraCrypt muss ja wohl ein Fork von Truecrypt sein.
Das heißt, es sollte zum Teil auch dafür gelten.
Was man natürlich nicht weiß, ob da nicht jetzt
zwischenzeitlich etwas eingebaut wurde.
Nichtsdestotrotz halte ich es für wichtiger,
maintainte Software zu verwenden als uralt Software,
die vielleicht mal irgendwann geoutet wurde.
Mal gucken, wie schnell die Seite aktualisiert.
Jetzt weiß ich später nicht, bei welcher Seite es geht.
Meinst du die hier? Schnell.
Eins hat die aktualisiert alle 3-4 Sekunden.
Kam vor einigen Wochen mal auf, schauen wir uns
mal gemeinsam die Einrichtung eines PXE-Servers an.
Wenn es sein muss, was hast du denn vor?
Ich bin eigentlich kein großartiger Fan mehr von PXE-Gebote.
Entweder ist es irgendwelches Cloud-Zeug,
was gleich von einem richtigen Image startet,
oder man macht halt einen USB-Stick dran,
wenn es ein richtiger Server ist,
und zieht sich das dann übers Netzwerk.
PXE-Server ist immer so ein krasses Rumgefrickel.
Da merkt man an, dass das irgendwie schon 25 oder 30 Jahre alt ist.
So, alle Fragen aus hier.
Haben wir es geschafft.
Haben wir alles beantwortet. Easy.
Schaut mal Leute, das macht mich zuversichtlich.
Wir sind jetzt bisher 2 Stunden 36 Minuten on.
Wir haben jetzt seit einer ganzen Weile
so um die 200 Zuschauer im Dreh.
Und ich hatte keinen Plan, in dem Moment,
wo ich den Stream angemacht habe,
ich hatte keinen Plan, was ich mache.
Das macht mich zuversichtlich, dass ich mir
für Streams nicht immer im Vorfeld was überlegen muss,
irgendwie, was man großartig machen könnte,
sondern ab und zu einfach auch mal schreiben kann,
ohne dass man was großartig geplant hat.
PXE im Docker.
Das ist natürlich die bessere Variante.
Da muss man den Kram nicht selbst konfigurieren.
Netboot XYZ.
Das ist tatsächlich eine ziemlich gute Seite.
Die kenne ich.
Das konnte man tatsächlich mal ausbilden.
Eine sehr gute Seite, die kenne ich.
Und zwar, was ich euch da mal zeigen muss zu...
Vielleicht gucken wir uns das wirklich mal an.
Wofür das sehr praktisch ist, Netboot XYZ,
das geht auch ohne PXE-Boot.
Das ist quasi so ein Mini-Image.
Ein Mini-Image, was man auch booten kann.
Kann man seinen Boot-Manager damit überschreiben.
Beim nächsten Boot landet man da drin.
Das ist ein Mini-Image mit einem Menü
und einem Netinstall für gängige Linux-Betriebssysteme.
Das ist sehr praktisch.
Ich habe euch ja schon öfters erzählt,
dass ich einen Server habe
bei so einem absolut räudigen Kack-Hoster.
Bei dem da.
Das war ein Angebot.
Der hat ultra gute Reviews, dieser Hoster.
Das ist quasi die creme de la creme der Hoster.
Die definieren ihre SLAs auch eher über Downtime als über Uptime.
Und bei denen habe ich mal einen Server gemietet
für 35 Dollar Lifetime.
Also ich habe einmal 35 Dollar bezahlt
vor sieben Jahren oder so.
Und seitdem ist er da.
Das Ding läuft wahrscheinlich
auf dem letzten Rotz an Hardware
und auf dem überbuchtesten ESX aller Zeiten.
Man hat ungefähr 2 MB die Sekunde Read-Write auf der Platte.
2 MB die Sekunde Megabyte die Sekunde Read-Write auf der Platte.
Der riesen Vorteil von dem Ding ist,
man hat eine statische feste IPv4-Adresse
und Netzwerk ist auch halbwegs geschwind.
Der Rest ist für den Arsch.
Und ich kann mich noch erinnern,
die waren aber gar nicht so schlecht.
Wir hatten da ein bisschen Probleme
mit der Minecraft-Server-Performance,
aber an sich waren die okay.
Aber die hier sind richtig schlecht.
Und was ich da gemacht habe ist,
weil die bieten nur ein Ubuntu 14.04-Image oder so an.
Also richtig Oldschool-Scheiß.
Das habe ich installiert
und die bieten keine Möglichkeit an ISO-Boot zu machen.
Vor allem bei 2 MB die Sekunde ist ja auch.
Und dann habe ich netboot.xyz genommen,
habe das ausgeführt mit einem Curl.
Man macht einfach einen Curl
und pipet das nach dd im Endeffekt
und dann überschreibt es den Crop.
Dann habe ich dann quasi über netboot.xyz
meinen Server rebooted
und dann ist es in das Menü reingegangen
und dann ist das Ubuntu 14.04
oder was das war zuletzt darauf installiert.
So und der Installer,
ich habe noch nie im Leben
eine so unglaublich langsame Ubuntu-Installation erlebt
wie hier, wie bei denen.
Mit 2 MB die Sekunde,
die Ubuntu-Installation,
die habe ich abends angestoßen, abends.
Abends, 18 Uhr oder so.
Und morgens am anderen Tag,
als ich auf der Arbeit gesessen habe
und mal reingeguckt habe,
war der immer noch am installieren.
Ich habe 24 Stunden Ubuntu installiert.
Das musste er erst mal schaffen.
Kann jemand zufällig
einen Android für einen alten Laptop empfehlen?
Warum muss es ein Android sein
für einen alten Laptop?
Android hat es mit Hardware-Unterstützung nicht so gut
und die x86-Android-Geschichten
sind auch meistens nicht so der Wahnsinn.
Wenn es ein alter Laptop ist,
je nachdem, was du machen willst,
kannst du dir einen Linux-Raum installieren.
Oder aber Windows 10.
Je nachdem, wie alt er ist,
Windows 10 läuft erstaunlich gut,
auch auf älterer Hardware.
Mit Android glaube ich nicht,
dass du glücklich wirst
auf einen normalen Laptop.
Mit Android glaube ich nicht,
dass du glücklich wirst auf einen normalen Laptop.
Wie du die Corona-Cases angezeigt kriegst,
hiermit.
Du machst einen Curl auf Corona.
Also normalerweise ist da auch
mehr in der Anzeige drin.
Guck, normalerweise kriegst du für alle Länder
den ganzen Kram.
Und ich habe jetzt einfach nur die letzten,
die oberen 20 Länder ausgegeben.
Also die oberen 10, weil es irgendwie
mehrere Zeilen sind.
Und das aktualisiert jetzt alle 2 Sekunden.
Jetzt haben wir quasi Live-Corona-Übersicht,
wie es hochgeht hier.
Aktuell haben wir 22.213 Fälle.
Und heute gab es
2.365 neue.
Man hat ja unten gerade gesehen,
in der Schweiz hat es aktualisiert.
Guck mal, in Südkorea,
funktioniert es.
Die Zahlen in China glaube ich ja nicht.
China glaube ich nicht.
Das glaube ich denen nicht.
Die geben einfach keine Zahlen raus.
Ach du willst Android-Apps nutzen?
Ja, ehrlich gesagt keine Idee.
Ich wollte selbst mal in nächster Zeit
auf einem Raspberry Pi in einem Android testen.
Gucken wie das so funktioniert.
Es gibt aber für
einen Desktop mittlerweile
halbwegs brauchbare Android-Emulator
die ganz gut funktionieren.
Habe ich letztens ein Video drüber gesehen.
Eigentlich ist nur die letzte Spalte
relevant.
Warum sollte das die einzig relevante Spalte sein?
Die fallen pro 1.000.000 Einwohner.
Wichtig ist
eigentlich das hier.
Wie viele neue Fälle es am Tag gibt.
Wenn man davon ausgeht, dass das nahezu exponentiell
reicht, ist das hier das Wichtige.
Ich glaube wir kriegen noch deutlich mehr Tote
in nächsten Tagen, weil
das hat ja bei uns erst so richtig angefangen
in der Woche.
Max, was hältst du von Investitionen
in Bitcoins?
Da habe ich ein Video zugemacht und im Prinzip
das Fazit aus diesem Video war,
das muss jeder selbst wissen und ich bin kein
Kryptocoinexperte.
Das ist ZSR.
Also wenn die Leute
sich ein bisschen dran halten,
dann glaube ich nicht, dass es so schlimm wird
wie in Italien.
Hast du schon mal Erfahrung
mit OVH gemacht?
Und kannst du dir... Was war denn das
noch mal?
Was war denn OVH
War sie eine Cloud-Geschichte?
Nee.
Meinst du das?
Nee, wenn du das meinst, habe ich damit noch keine
Erfahrung gemacht.
OVH?
Ein Haus da.
Hm.
Die da?
Meint ihr die hier?
Wie ist eigentlich so der Bitcoin-Kurs?
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Oh, es wird da ganz schön runter
geflutscht hier.
Und jetzt wieder ordentlich hoch.
Nee, mit denen habe ich noch keinerlei Erfahrung
gemacht, ehrlich gesagt.
Warum fragst du, was
macht die aus?
Also warum sollte man die kennen?
OVH?
Was haben wir da so zu bieten?
Okay, von der VM reicht mir aus.
Sind Franzosen.
Ja gut, das ist jetzt einfach kein Grund dafür, warum
man zu denen sollte, oder?
Das ist weder ein Grund dafür, noch dagegen.
Starke RAM-Ausstattung.
Ah, vielleicht könnte ich da mal ein Open-Street-Maps-
euch drauf.
OVH?
MonkaS Windows.
Das ist einfach das Doppelte.
Ah, ganz normal Eindruck.
Schau dir Scaleway an.
Also ich habe bisher eigentlich nur
von der Arbeit noch so ein bisschen
habe ich Azure verwendet, wobei Azure ja kein klasser
Hoster ist.
Du kannst halt auch VMs hosten, aber das ist nicht
zum Zweck der Sache.
Und ansonsten verwende ich eigentlich, ich habe schon mal
bei Hetzer was gemietet, und ansonsten
wenn ich kurzzeitig was brauche,
nehme ich Digital Ocean.
Und dann habe ich ja noch meinen 35 Dollar
Lifetime-VM-Server.
Was brauchen wir Instances?
GPU-Instances?
Boah!
Uiuiui!
Ah ja ja!
Das könnte ich gebrauchen!
GIF!
Boah!
Krasser Shit!
Boah, 56 Gigabyte RAM!
So ein Ding könnte ich wirklich mal gebrauchen
für ein paar Stunden,
dass ich mein Open-Street-Maps-Geschiss
extrahiert bekomme.
Wobei ich lasse das einfach auf meiner 4HE-Kiste laufen,
die hat auch 48G RAM.
Mit Swap reicht das dicke.
Eats.
Haben wir gemacht!
Ja Leute, oh, es ist 22 Uhr!
Gut, es ist Wochenende,
aber trotzdem, neue Früh gibt es ja wieder Aufwachen-Stream.
Ah ja, zur Erklärung,
wieso PXE?
Wir müssen mal kurz hier ein ordentliches
Emote installieren.
Global Twitch Emotes.
Ah, yes, excellent.
Warum geht das hier nicht?
Ah, weil da keine Emotes drin sind.
Gibt es schon Battlefield-Klips?
Ja, dieses Wochenende ist soweit,
morgen ist soweit, Battlefield-Video.
Morgen ist soweit.
Ich habe es mir fest vorgenommen,
morgen ist soweit.
Ich brauche mal eine Nachricht
mit einem Emote drin.
Nee, funktioniert nicht.
Warum nicht?
Ah, hier.
Ah, ich habe mich gespeichert.
Wo bloß?
Nee, es ist kaputt, Leute.
Es geht nicht.
Ah.
Ah, yes.
Excellent.
Jetzt funktioniert was.
Seit wann streamst du denn?
Seit...
2 Stunden 52,
aber auch nicht mehr allzu lange, weil ich gehe gleich ins Bett.
Ähm...
Sehr schön.
Äh, zur Erklärung.
Wieso PXE?
Setze meinen Rechner gerne mal spontan neu auf.
Da erkenne ich mich wieder.
Das habe ich früher auch gerne gemacht.
Und vergesse dann meist zu prüfen,
ob ich Bootsticks habe,
um dem aus dem Weg zu gehen,
dann halt PXE.
Aber ich scheitere da an manchen Umsetzungen.
Und Docker ist mir völlig fremd.
Ähm...
Dieser Docker-Container,
den sie hier vorhin gepostet haben,
der hier, der an der Chat vorhin gepostet,
der hier, der da.
Ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert,
aber ich habe netboot.xyz ausprobiert.
Das hat wunderbar funktioniert.
Und wenn das einfach nur ein Docker starten ist,
dann ist das total einfach.
Das musst du nicht machen.
Ich würde dir empfehlen, guck dir einfach mal
ein Docker-Tutorial an.
Ich meine, du bist ja eh unterwegs.
Und an so ein bisschen den Container-Basics
kommt man eigentlich heute kaum noch vorbei.
Guck dir einfach mal
in so 30 Minuten Docker-Introduktion an.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich simpel.
Wenn man mal ein bisschen dahinter gestiegen ist.
Man muss auch überhaupt nicht verstehen,
wie es unter der Haube funktioniert.
Sondern einfach nur wie die Docker-Commandline funktioniert.
Ähm...
Ich finde daran ist,
dass du eben den Kram
starten kannst, bei dir lokal,
halt so, und hast einen fertig
funktionierenden PXE-Server.
Und wenn du wieder wegkommen willst,
löscht du den Container und er ist halt widerstandslos
vom System wieder weg.
Also das scheint mir die beste Alternative zu sein,
anstatt PXE selbst zusammenzufrickeln.
Ich habe PXE schon selbst
zusammengefrickelt, das ist nicht schön.
Wie gesagt, morgen Battlefield,
Leute, morgen Battlefield.
Bei mir auf YouTube, endlich hier.
Ich habe es mir fest vorgenommen,
morgen nehme ich auf.
Also, das ist bestimmt
weit hergeholt.
Sagt, äh...
Ali...
Oder Ali...
Okay, ich weiß nicht, wie was...
Wir bleiben bei Ali, ist glaube ich besser.
Also das ist bestimmt
mehr Gold, aber nach meiner Meinung denke ich,
dass es mit Corona ausarten wird.
Ich denke, die Währung in Schein
oder Münzen wäre in naher Zukunft kein Wert mehr.
Ne, das glaube ich nicht.
Welches Battlefield? Na das, wo die Leute
mir die Clips für geschickt haben.
Ich habe hier im Stream Battlefield
Plays gesammelt, richtig gute Plays
und da mache ich für YouTube einen...
ähm...
Best of...
Best of Battlefield Clips.
Ja.
Hatte auch einen PXE, ist aber am Laufen,
aber da konnte kein EFI.
Äh... Moment, Moment.
Ähm...
Sollte PXE nicht eine ganze Ecke nach
danach kommen?
Sowohl EFI als auch...
Netzwerkboot machen. Ich weiß gar nicht,
ob man... Muss man bei PXE...
Ist bei PXE eine besondere
Anforderung für EFI?
Siehst du mal, wie wenig ich damit gemacht habe.
Oh, EFI Mode.
Kann das Ding auch.
Ja, Tribolon, mal gucken.
Wenn ich noch mehr Videos machen will,
dann muss ich das sagen, ja.
Also ich würde tatsächlich für einen einfachen...
für einen einfachen PXE-Sopfer
würde ich tatsächlich das hier mal probieren.
Also, lass dieses ganze Unraid-Gelaber hier weg.
Das hier ist das Entscheidende,
was du brauchst, da.
Und eigentlich brauchst du...
Das kannst du weglassen.
Äh...
Konf...
Fick...
Ich weiß nicht, ob man die braucht.
Oder ob da eine dabei ist, standardmäßig.
Kannst du weglassen.
Das brauchst du eigentlich auch nicht, wenn das als Route ausführst.
Wobei, Docker-Container als Route ist,
ist eine Glaubensfrage.
Das können wir mal ausprobieren.
Ich schreibe mir das mal auf.
PXE-Docker testen.
Das schreibe ich mal auf. Das können wir wirklich mal
ausprobieren.
So.
Ach so, okay.
Ja, C...
2, H, O, ähm...
Ich weiß da nichts zu sagen.
Jetzt bin ich nicht gut genug mit aus.
Oh, guck mal, Frames haben gedroppt.
Frametrops sind raus.
Gut, Leute, wir sehen uns morgen früh.
Ich guck jetzt mal, was die Katze so macht.
Krieg sie noch ein bisschen futtern,
dass sie heute Nacht nicht nur rumnervt.
Wobei, abends, die will ja...
Die will ja nachts gar nichts futtern, ne?
Ähm... Also nichts richtiges futtern.
Die will...
Abends will die immer...
Whiskers Knuspertaschen haben.
Wenn ich der abends keine Whiskers
Knuspertaschen gebe,
dann kratzt die nach 20 Minuten
bei mir an der Schlafzimmertür
und will rein.
Ja, so ungefähr sieht das bei
meiner auch aus.
So liegt sie oben auf dem Schrank hier.
Da hat sie ganz schön dicke Bobbes
auf dem Bild, ja.
Okay, jetzt heu ich weg.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns morgen.
Macht's gut.
Äh...
Wir sehen uns morgen.
Paya...